all right hey what's going on it's Bill
Byrne it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast and I'm just checking in
on you and you know if I have the video
on that means that I have a guest
uh this guy's an absolute Legend
um Not only was he the star of uh the
original Christmas story he also was uh
one of the many driving forces behind F
is for family
um throughout the years when we did that
show I became great friends with this
guy and uh and he is here now with us
the one and only Peter Billingsley
what's going on yeah man maybe the
greatest introduction I've ever gotten
thank you Bill I'm trying I'm trying I'm
hearing I'm here I'm here at Bally's
that just became the horseshoe
I met up with some of my high school
buddies went to that [ __ ] Raiders
game yesterday or you did you were live
oh my God
yeah well the biggest problem I had was
them go that defense that they used to
give them the opportunity to get there
but that [ __ ] at the end man it was just
Keystone cop stuff but it was hilarious
yeah
um and of course somebody's giving me a
[ __ ] call in an hour uh um all right
well let me talk let's get down to what
you're here for uh you are here to
promote
um
a movie that is doing outstanding you
don't really even need me but I just
wanted to hang out I'm here to say hi
first and foremost here to spend a
little time with my guy that's right
that's right you used to live right down
the street from me no more uh Christmas
Story 2 is out right now uh the weight
is already A Christmas Story Christmas
not two why the [ __ ] does this say two
up there it's a Christmas Story
Christmas
uh the long-awaited follow-up to the
enduring favorite that fans everywhere
keep on their annual must watch list
it's finally arriving just in time to
kick off the holiday season this
heartwarming and humor-filled next
chapter in Richie Parker's tale finds
him grown with his own family determined
uh to create an unforgettable Christmas
for his kids because that's what you do
as a dad and of course right as is
tradition in the park a household
despite dad's best efforts to make those
spirits bright things go comically awry
and hijinks and Sue in this endearing
relatable
slice of family life uh I've never heard
that blurb before yeah
trying to get uh they're basically
saying there's no full frontal nudity in
that yeah it's this is a family friendly
one unlike the show we did this one's
family friendly yeah
the first one that you were a kid and
now you get to it literally
play like the dad role and now you have
two kids of your own
um I've only seen the trailer because I
just been on the road finishing up this
other project I noticed in like the
trailer like I just saw the trailer I
really enjoyed you're acting just to the
trailer those little flurries as I look
at that he's really like grounded in
this and you know because I worked with
you for like seven eight years totally
and I just saw you as a producer go and
build that doesn't track it'll do it
again Bill we can't save rewriting yeah
so then to actually watch you uh like
acting and I was thinking like you you
had so much to like uh draw from with
two young kids you know you wanted to
make it you know perfect I was looking
up I was trying to find if there's ever
been
like this long of a a kid character to
an adult I mean even let alone any kid
character to an adult in a sequel and
it's been 39 years
I couldn't find anything uh it's like
the Top Gun of Christmas movies it kind
of made me breathing longer than Tom and
at least he was a grown-up in the first
one or kind of how did they get you uh
signed on to this thing because I I
would just picture if they said hey
we're gonna do another one your initial
reaction would be like oh God you know
they're going back to the well what are
we gonna do like uh no of of course I
mean I've been developing this for about
four years so I started working with the
guys over at legendary
um oh okay kale if you know kale boiter
and those guys in Mary Perrin and Jay
and obviously people have approached me
for years and said you know oh you
should come back and do Ralph I mean
you're a good looking guy Peter I
imagine
hopefully it's more than that
but it was never a great idea and so we
just kind of started similar to how we
worked right like you had an idea and
then you just sort of slowly build on
the layers that you like about it and so
it was you're right it was starting with
it'd be cool to look at ralphia's dad
and it was this sort of thesis that we
were around where when you're a kid you
really want the perfect Christmas gift
but when you're a parent you want
Christmas to be perfect for your kid and
it's sort of that gift right where
you're devoted to that and then really
this movie starts with the passing of
the old man so it's sort of Mythic and
moving into the patriarchy and and you
know Ralph has to sort of step into that
and so it's this call to action at an
important point in his life it's done
comedically but also has a lot of heart
and so as we started building the pieces
I got more excited about it and just
felt like I wasn't going to move forward
ultimately unless we had it right you
know we hired Nick shank do you know
Nick he's a great writer he wrote
written a lot of Clint Eastwood stuff he
wrote Gran Torino the mule you know we
wanted to start with now his next thing
is he does a a Christmas story
he's pretty versatile pretty versatile
but also like wanted to start with a guy
who's got a little more grit right he's
from the Midwest he's from Minnesota so
we started building pieces and then I
felt like all right this isn't a spot
where it feels like we could pull the
trigger and go with this thing because
you talk about a sequel that has
they all have pressure all movies have
pressure on them to succeed but this
thing is borderline religious for people
this movie you know it's so sacred so
you don't want to do something that's
going to [ __ ] on it or impact it
negatively and so to give you a sports
analogy I would always say to everyone
like yeah you got to play offense right
you got to go make something that's good
be entertaining you got to play defense
too on this movie like you can't make
decisions that negatively influence the
first movie
so did you uh once you announced that it
was going
to happen did you stay off social media
because I was like an answer oh yeah the
haters come out they always do that like
oh this is [ __ ] I'm gonna screw this
up yeah cash grab think of something
else to do and I just said to everyone I
said just wait you know it's fine that's
gonna start yeah I'm gonna go through
these phases you're gonna release a
trailer a lot of people gonna go this
looks great you're gonna get that same
what are they doing oh what is this uh
you know what they do that all the time
every couple of years it seems they do a
new Joker movie and some poor actor gets
the part of the Joker and then it's just
like oh my god oh no it's stopped and I
just sit there going like if you ever
sign on there's certain roles in
Hollywood if you sign on to do them it's
just like you have to say on social
media right through the press and then
years later asked did it do well that's
what I said I said you know what let's
see where the dust settles in five years
you know the last one found a life of
its own I'm not saying we're going to do
that but it's just it's a Christmas
movie they're going to be perennials
they're going to come back just don't
worry guys go make something that we all
believe in and we'll check in in five
years and see where things sit and so
far so good it's been a really
I would say overwhelmingly positive
response critically and from fans they
get what we did they appreciate what we
did and no we weren't you you're never
going to be better than that movie and
no one was trying to but it doesn't have
to stop you from telling another story
in the chapter
no I feel like it's like it's a
different movie where it's um
so you had like the all like
you already went through being a kid and
all your hopes of getting that gift that
you wanted and all of that
and the ups and downs the stuff that
disappointed you about Christmas and how
your parents were there's a lot of
people you know they get older and they
have like kids and the the [ __ ]
pressure
yes that you put on yourself to be like
oh my God what if I screw this up what
if what if I I I you know what if my
kids hate me and think that I I don't
know right all right I say the wrong
thing and I give them a complex and
stuff it's uh there's a lot of uh a lot
of pressure especially if you had a dad
and like in that movie who was a great
dad and like got him to get you know in
that original movie The dad's the only
person in the movie he doesn't ask for
the gun and just to instinctively knew
to get it for him so it's like you got
this great dad that's like full of
great wisdom college to be so it's like
huge shoes to fill so we you know
definitely play with those tropes that I
think are relatable and to Ralphie and I
agree certainly to me I mean I don't
know what I'm doing with this Christmas
stuff I'm trying to figure it out
sometimes I'm like you know what you
just default to your wife because they
know what to do they just get a bunch of
[ __ ] yeah yeah they decorate the house
you stay out of the way which is funny
because then they'll get like upset that
you're not like contributing it's like
well if I start talking then I'm just
going to upset you because I'm gonna be
like here
I said just take some of his pre take
some of his toys off the shelf and wrap
them you know we don't need to buy a
bunch of new stuff just wrap the ones he
has and be like oh look at this he's
only one he's not gonna know he's gonna
get excited to pull yeah you know what I
mean you don't have to go buy all this
new crap that sits on the shelves
I know that's like a uh you know my kids
have a zillion relatives and they're
always like getting them stuff because
they love my kids which is awesome my
kids get to feel all that love and
everything but dude these kids they got
more goddamn toys
in my life I know this year we're gonna
like grab a bunch of stuff and try to
donate it somewhere where you can give
used toys to at least a get rid of the
Clutter but B try to teach that message
like guys we got to be grateful for well
we have you got a lot more than most
kids right what do you what's your
stance on video games
not yet I don't know my daughter's five
I mean selfishly I want to start playing
with her a little bit you know
so it's like that's awesome that's
awesome we're a little I think my wife
knows the slippery slope it can go I
mean I know it too from you know living
in my 20s single I I remember the the
dark slippery slope it can turn into two
dude four in the morning so I'm watching
the sun come up and it's just like dude
you gotta go to bed one more one more
and you can't stop so I know I stopped
up I tapped out Grand Theft Auto three I
was up at like four in the [ __ ]
morning
or would have been Medal of Honor it was
one of those games
I was on stage doing stand-up and I was
trying to figure out how to beat the
next level and I came home
and I started playing it and I couldn't
get to sleep and I was asleep until one
and two in the afternoon just feeling
like a [ __ ] loser right so I uh
you know I am not mechanically like
electronically inclined I came home and
I just unplugged [ __ ] everything and
wadded it up and I just stuck it in the
back of the uh the closet I haven't
pulled it out since
never
never used it again never played video
games again I mean I can't imagine what
video games are like now because uh
uh one of my buddies Patrice got me to
this game siphon filter he goes dude you
got to get to the level with the bridge
man the bridge is amazing so I you know
what's funny is to me those are all new
games to me asteroids yeah totally
totally yeah
I think it was like 50 attempts from
what was the one where you had the plane
that you had to fly it was like you this
is so stupid I'm like this guy's a
career criminal he's doing great and now
he gets here and he's got a flyer radio
control plane and it drove me nuts right
finally finally it was before you could
easily Google like what's the hack you
know
and so you had to figure it out I mean I
guess that was part of the appeal and
then I the the one that really put me
over the edge was a game called the god
The Godfather was another it was great
it was another thing like you had to
move through
this thing but it was set like in the
gangster times in the 40s
and I remember yeah you're just gonna
get lost in that that they were too good
20 years ago I remember when I was in
Grand Theft Auto I was trying to do
something where you had to race this car
around the city and then make it to the
finish line and I didn't realize I kept
stealing the wrong car I kept stealing
like that Chevy Nova was like the
flamethrowers and I needed to feel like
the [ __ ] Porsche and I got so good
with that Chevy Nova that one time I
they were shooting at me and I got all
the way to the final stretch of the
finish line and the car started glowing
like it was going to be on fire and I
just went like no and it blew up right
before it and I went [ __ ] you know she's
like it was like three in the morning
and I just went like I hate this goddamn
[ __ ] sucking [ __ ] game right
and then I hear the two gay guys who
lived next door who were walking in I
heard him [ __ ] burst out laughing and
I was like oh my God like what is
what is [ __ ] like
did you ever have a moment after like
driving that car the way you did where
you got into your own car and you had to
check yourself for a minute I would 100
after like four or five in the morning
and you're like man I gotta go to
7-Eleven get like some water or
something and I'd get in and gun it and
it was like Whoa stop you are not in the
game anymore
totally dude well all right we're really
in rabbit hole but I'll show one last
thing like how much I found myself
getting too distracted by just like
running around and then just like
cracking someone and then keep running
yeah you win all the stupid stuff that
you could do when the missions got too
hard I would avoid it just go wandering
the police
precincts you could go into the back of
the jail cell there was one and if you
had like a fully automated weapon they
just keep coming around the corner like
there was all this stuff that I would
because once those guys showed up on
those black Caprice Classics before the
Army showed up and you basically you
would toast unless you had the cheats
but once the Army showed up you had to
be able to shoot them and do the cheat
to keep getting your life back
oh yeah I remember one time coming out
of my apartment after playing one of
these those sniper games forever and I
was just looking at people across the
street like that
all of their heads and I was like I know
all right you're like it looks like 80
yards wind a little from the Northwest
two click South I got you baby and just
they have no idea that you're thinking
it
I remember the chick I was seeing at the
time came over
when I was playing that game and when I
[ __ ] shot somebody the sound of it
and the guy's head blowing up she
actually burst it out laughing
it was passed and I was like this is
this is pretty bad right and he's like
no you know you know it's definitely
graphic
guys will be guys
so I think my uh my daughter wants uh
like uh Nintendo switch or something
like that we're debating whether that's
going to happen and whatever but I mean
you can do like the Mario games like
jumping ringing getting coins like you
can start you don't have to start at
Grand Theft Auto which I probably
wouldn't advise
you know but I know it's a slippery
slope but then you have to manage the
time and then they want it and they get
addicted to it it's like TV even you
know I don't know about your kids you
know what's funny in mainland China the
majority of their Tick Tock summer was
telling me is all science-based that's
because the government
um sort of controls it or whatever
because it left to their own devices I'm
sure mainland China the Ice Bucket
Challenge and doing that whatever that
dance is
um you got your foot going too yeah yeah
so it's like uh
I don't know I'm just gonna I think you
were saying that you you'll play with
your kid
doing it you know together that's the
fun way to do it I'm just gonna work I
have a buddy who plays like sports games
so like as your son gets into sports
he'll do the FIFA soccer and stuff and
they love it and they'll do The Hoots
games and it's funny to be on the same
team and play and it seems like it's
something they enjoy and maybe it
doesn't have quite the addictive nature
of slapping around or sniping random
humans on the street yeah no violence or
anything yeah exactly yeah so um
anyway so when this movie came out I got
I have just a question I have is when
you did press for this thing
um like so much stuff for this business
has changed I remember a long time ago
I went to a bar and one of the actors
from The Hangover was in there and he
had this look of relief on his face and
he had just done a world tour of
promoting the final one yeah and I
forget where they sent him but at one
point he connected in the Canary Islands
uh this guy just was like he was like
the best move yeah exhausted so I know
now you look at this like zoom and stuff
you can just do it this way is is it
easier than say like you know when back
in the day when you had to promote a
film or something like that in some ways
it's easier I did I've always been an
advocate of regional advertising I know
you are with your stand-up you used to
tell me how you would you were an early
adopter of going to foreign countries
where Netflix was going to go right and
build up kind of a local fan base and
you can't deny that and I think even in
your tour dates you hit yeah you know
it's not just the 10 largest cities in
America and so is one of the things I
said Warner Brothers when we were
hatching the plan I said I want to do
some of this Regional approach which I
used to do a ton as a kid because this
movie is also like about small tan
American small towns love this movie all
across the country you know this is not
right it's it's it's about kind of
working class Folk right that are
working hard in cold weather climates
trying to have a good life so I wanted
to connect so I did some screenings in
some cities flew around hit Chicago they
did
um one in uh Cleveland
um of course which is where we shot the
first one and so I did some traveling
not on the international level and then
yeah a lot of zooms the weird you know
the weird thing if you've done a junket
in a while like the old press junkets
where you would sit yeah you take it to
a hotel
they take you to a hotel and you sit
down and just one person after another
comes in and asks you right A lot of the
same questions that's right and you and
they would like each get a tape right so
they put the tape in the camera they
recorded and they hand them the tape
they and they leave now they still take
you to like a hotel room that they
decorate but it's all Zoom so you're
just sitting in a room alone and I guess
most people prefer it I don't I like
human interaction so I like being with
someone and they're kind of cookie
personalities because they're different
because there's a lot of local Regional
like the weather guy or the news guy and
they get to do the entertainment thing I
didn't it drives some people nuts but I
think it's funny but a lot of people
showed up in their Christmas Story
sweaters on zoom and stuff when we were
doing the junket and things and some
people I think one dude had a bunny suit
on I mean that's probably better over
Zoom
if I'm being frank it's like the
separation right circumstance is good
how do you handle somebody when they go
there and they just go like they're not
there to interview you as much as
they're there to try to piss you off and
hopefully you'll save some wild [ __ ] and
then they can get some looks you know
where uh I I've seen like a there's a
few people that you know
I know and for whatever reason they're
like magnets for that [ __ ] people will
come in and just say really really just
disrespectful stuff and it's just like
man they're just trying to get you
they're just trying to get you well
they'll do one or two things right
they'll do the disrespectful thing or
they'll try to pull out something in
your movie that is totally not true or
why it's disrespectful to a certain
group or something
which is a little more like passive
aggressive but I'll generally not answer
their question with the talking point
that I want
so it's like they could say you know
what color is the sky and I'll just say
you know what I really love about this
movie is that it's relatable and I think
it really hit and I'll just oh you go
Bill Clinton on him I just I'm like I'm
not even gonna engage I've been around
too long to know you know this is a
great country if you start talking about
others exactly did you insert yourself
to that woman I love America
but it's kind of Genius it works you
know it's it's like I just can't believe
no one ever goes that's not the question
I asked
I've said I'm here to promote the movie
um and that but it's yeah I I
fortunately not been a huge Target for
that but it's like I look I love the
interviews when they do take debate and
then you see an actor going you know who
the hell you asking me this foreign
like you want to do that but then I'm
just like oh man now we're going viral
for the wrong reasons my first instinct
when you said you know this part of the
movie seemed to be offensive to this
type of group and I'll be like oh good
that's what we were going for yeah you
could also do that too we make
polarizing moves not only were we making
a Christmas movie we wanted we wanted a
group of people that would have spent
money to go see it to be unbelievably
offended by it like uh that was that was
a deal breaker in my contract that I had
to offend the advantage we had was that
this one takes place in 1973 because the
original one was 40 so it's like 33
years later for Ralphie right so it's so
[ __ ] cool so think of all the great
conversations that we had on F is for
family about hey we don't have to
necessarily subscribe to the new comedy
police in 2020 19 when we were doing it
it's like it's back in 73 so not that
we're an edgy movie but it just kind of
gives you that same freedom of like it's
a different time also I love movies with
no cell phones so from plot you can have
someone leave like I leave twice I come
home at like four in the morning and the
wife's like oh it's late it's like yeah
it's like you can't get a hold of anyone
there's a joke about
um there's a bar and like the the phone
in the bar rings and the music shuts off
and it gets really I had the bartenders
like because the wives used to call the
books so it's fun to take advantage of
the time period like that
um and so if your wife knows the number
without having to look it up of the
local [ __ ] you drink it too much yeah we
could definitely drinking too much but
that's what happened do you know what
one thing that they did I've seen it
done right but it's really hard to do it
is when they show two people texting
each other in a movie and then they got
to show the text on the screen it's
really hard to do that well to keep the
momentum going and I at first I didn't
like it then I was like well no this is
this is what people do now
it's just people that make movies
haven't necessarily figured out how to
do it in a way that it doesn't slow the
movie Down
um I feel like the big thing is that the
character you can do it in like a
suspenseful time
of a movie and if the character is still
moving look looking for something and
texting like that I feel like yeah the
momentum is is kept
by like the action I guess I don't know
but it's a really uh
I don't know like I
I don't mind it now I think you're right
it's a convention because it's like it's
so much how we communicate you have to
deal with it I was grateful not to deal
with any of that stuff because it is
kind of a pain in the ass that people
like why didn't you why didn't you just
text him if he was out or why didn't she
just call it's like you don't want to
hear any of that stuff
you know what's funny about older movies
I watched uh Thief James Khan oh yeah
one of one of the tropes back then I
don't know if it was tropes but if you
wanted to show
like the gangster was being tough they
always said wildly racist [ __ ] like hit
the movie like let me tell you something
potato face if you don't stop [ __ ]
around all that poor police he walks at
this [ __ ] door then you can shake a
[ __ ] queer at and it's just like God
damn like damn like [ __ ] they just
like it was this guy uh
oh he's threatening that he was gonna if
he didn't do what he's gonna do he's
gonna put his wife out on the street to
get [ __ ] in the ass but he didn't say
it like that yeah yeah yeah and you
watched the movie like watching the cars
and enjoying it like what all right I
get it this guy does not give a [ __ ]
Jesus guys not to be messed with the
message received sir you know it's funny
that was one of my favorite characters
that's still just doesn't get a lot of
love is do you remember Johnny
dangerously with Joe piscopal yeah
totally yeah you remember Roman Maroney
yeah he was the guy he was the Immigrant
who cursed his brains out oh yes all the
curses yes and he'd be like let me tell
you [ __ ] I saw something I'm gonna
have your bells in this sling and then
the other guy would be like Jesus the
mouth on that guy you farted way of
doing it yeah and he gets deported
claims he's not from there like that
Roman varody was one of my that that
movie uh Michael Keaton all of that is
just so uh it's good yeah definitely
definitely
um underrated so I gotta ask some car
questions here dude if you got if you
got a movie that takes place in the 70s
um what's uh what's Ralphie as an adult
what's his car
um Pontiac
um and
um he drives so his dad was a Pontiac
man
right so oh in the first one he drove a
Pontiac the dad did yeah and Ralph's a
um uh Plymouth guy
um we have
so we Shot the movie in Bulgaria did you
know that
no but I imagine you saved a shitload of
money if you went all the way over there
and we could build a lot of stuff we
built 11 houses we built like Ralphie's
like the Parker House the Bumpus house
next door and 11 houses on that street
the great thing about being there was
you could build we built we've literally
built the entire neighborhood and I mean
built it like for real like real
structures with Windows and Doors it was
amazing how'd you get the cars over
there they had all these classic cars
because they're starting to do a lot of
movies and I think they're doing
different like action movies and stuff
and they're sourcing cars so they
actually had some old
a lot of old cars which was awesome so I
was shocked I figured we'd have to get a
ton of them but they had them half of
them didn't run I mean there was a lot
of guys pushing jumping starving yeah
but you kind of get it taken they Coast
through but my Plymouth was what do you
call it three on the three of the column
three of the three which was kind of
cool so I did a little driving lesson
for that it was originally orange we we
painted it to green and then there's
there was one moment where I drive fast
and then and they really let me do it
and I drove and I got the fishtail as I
kind of popped out which is cool wow
that's so much fun it helps all that
stuff really helps put you into
character too like the clothing we got
to grow side sideburns everyone did a
you know some you I was saying it was
like the hockey playoffs you know when
you guys are forced to grow beers and it
kind of exposes who can do it and who
can't yeah I had I still haven't typed
it but I had some decent sideburns
because Ralphie's you're grounded lead
so he can't be crazy but the guy who
plays flick named Scott Schwartz he got
full muttons It's pretty dope and he
could grow them so we had something with
it
well that's that era we used to talk
about that on F is for family where a 25
year old guy looked like he was 43. yeah
I don't know I don't know what it was it
was something about the long hair and
the facial hair and to this day started
long hair and then the chops and then
the stash yeah you just I mean you look
like a man young yeah I don't I well I I
remember too like being when you were a
kid if I looked at a guy who's 25 years
old and he had that look and he was
leaning against his car smoking a
cigarette I was like that guy knows
everything
he's got it all figured out now I look
back I think about myself as 25 I was
like oh my God I was a kid yeah I didn't
know a [ __ ] thing yeah you're playing
video games till four o'clock in the
morning it's like there's a lot of Life
out there I hate to tell you this dude
that was actually my early 30s it was
even worse dude it was nice in my 30s I
know we were into Madden a lot too we'd
get dude at one point we were so into
we would play the college football game
okay and we had you know how you would
play both sides of the ball we didn't
you could get this remember the brick
and you could put four controllers into
it right so you had four controllers
dude so we had eight guys
dedicated offense dedicated defense and
we had our same team and we would play
against the computer and then I was a
designated kicker I was so obsessed that
if they were driving I'd open the door
and start stretching and kicking my foot
like I was a field goal kicker really
warming
and then I'd come in you know and you
get sentenced like you know to kick it
yeah you nail it and get the angle just
right
um but that's all that stuff that ended
up in swingers right that was all when
you guys were all living over you were
doing it after yeah I mean that was the
real stuff they were doing hockey and
swingers we took it to
later to a crazy level we were dedicated
my only job was a defensive lineman I
happened to kicker as well Vince played
Safety then we had a linebacker and we
had an interior alignment and that was
the only four guys job the entire night
and then you had offense the other four
guys beat high five and switch like
running off the field it was nuts dude
like it was crazy when they punt his
thumb is the coolest things ever it was
like and if it was like for real it was
like fantasy football before fantasy
football on the video game like we were
living as though we were defensive
lineman and running backs it was fun it
was really fun I mean that was sort of
where we took it but that was fun
because we'd make it like a dude's night
but we get some beer and some pizza and
hang out and as everyone was getting
older as Easter spent time together so
we sort of centered it around that but
it was fun
that's amazing who else is uh who else
is in the movies
all the Kid cast comes back so the kid
so my brother and all the actual actors
playing it which was phenomenal which
was another reason like another sort of
box I wanted to check to to do this
um Scott Farkas the bully
um Grover Dill his Toady
um flick and Schwartz and Randy all come
back dude how surreal was that the first
day when you were on your network Beyond
so we were finishing construction on
those houses that I was saying and
like they were putting the last coat of
paint on a house and then the guys were
starting to blow the snow on the trees
for the next morning shooting and it was
the evening and I looked around I'm like
oh my God we're back and I called the
guys they were in the hotel and I said
you got to get down here right now
just have your drivers drive you right
now and they came down and got out of
the car and looked and
just we all had this moment like man
we're back like this world is recreated
and we're in it and for them you know I
had been working on it for a while but I
asked them how they felt and they said
it was shockingly more emotional like
they really kind of got a little
overwhelmed in a good way with a lot of
a lot of emotion you know the movie is
such an interesting movie when it's kind
of hits this sort of iconic status just
how embedded and a part of it all the
people that are in it are sometimes you
don't realize it I think and it's just
it repeats and there's fans and they've
got a house that's you know the original
house is a museum and
it's in you know the Library of Congress
and all these places it
you have this Association that you
almost don't
realize until you stop and think about
it and I think for them to be back was
just a real powerful experience and it
was cool for us to be together because
we had not really been together as a
posse I've seen all the guys
in parts and pieces throughout the years
so it was it was really cool to be there
and to be able to just sort of bond in
that memory and I think you really you
really feel the friendships and the
connections it feels like kind of like
when you go home you know it's about
Ralphie going home he goes back to the
old neighborhood and he lives in Chicago
he lives in a big city trying to make
his bones and it's not going well for
him
um
you feel that
you know and it was cool to to imagine
okay where where are these guys now 30
odd years later where's flicking
Schwartz personally that that's my
favorite thing
um about movies when they do that or um
even like when Animal House ended and
they said what people ended up doing
like to me that was always like
fascinating to me it was why I liked the
Back to the Future Trilogy Where I I
loved when like yes yeah like Biff was
like you know he made all this money and
all the sports gambling thing and like
and
um you know the first one where you know
he switches it and then all of a sudden
he's got the he had the cool Toyota
pickup truck with the four-wheel drive
and his family was actually like winners
and stuff I find um
I don't know why because I am a
Sentimental person and then I also like
you know I went to high school with like
a bunch of
you know cool people so I had I had a
genuinely like love for the people that
I went to school with the grades above
me and below me like there's just really
a lot of cool people and uh
you know when I run into them on the
road
just hearing their stories what they're
doing and what they ended up now they
have like kids like uh I was did uh
Houston recently and I ran into this kid
not kid anymore we're both in our 50s
but this dude is arguably one of the
funniest [ __ ] guys I ever met he had
me laughing so hard eighth grade went by
in like three weeks I did terrible in
school all this dude just did was make
me laugh so good and and to run into him
all of those years later you know his
kids are grown and all of that and he's
like you know settled into married life
yeah and uh you know an adult and a
mature thing but every once in a while I
just poked him a little bit got him
going I saw that flicker in his eye
again I'm like there he is there he is
yeah that's the thing and I think
sometimes those relationships you cement
younger you know they can carry when you
remain friends and obviously life
changed so it's it's fun to imagine
where they are sometimes
you know not as predictable as you might
think and other times sort of like yeah
that's probably where I would kind of
imagine that guy to wind up to be so
that was it's fun to kind of when you
can create those characters that when
you just have a blank page and it's you
know and we involved them you know once
we kind of had it baked we brought them
over early and we rehearsed with them
and kind of got their take and everyone
was able to help sort of shape their
stuff a little bit so that was that was
a very fun process for me I know it's
going to be great because I've worked
with you and when I tell people you know
the stereotype of Hollywood is that
everybody's just [ __ ] you know
kicking it in a pool you know drinking a
margarita like living a cigar all day
yeah like you got like all of this free
time it's like
I try to tell I was like dude you don't
understand like the people that are
really doing well out there like the
level
um
it's not physical it's that brain [ __ ]
like I remember the first time we went
through an animatic
we did F is for family and for those of
you guys never did an animated show like
that first season is so hard because you
you don't know what the characters look
like and it can't look like any other
animated show so when you do an eye like
okay that's that's too much like
Scooby-Doo and Johnny quested this or
whatever
and I was joking you have to almost come
up with like your own race of animated
characters like okay yeah you can't go
yellow because everybody on The Simpsons
is yellow right you can't do the the
cheesy animation because the South Park
guys have done that
and uh but I remember we went through
that first animatic
went through the whole [ __ ] thing and
it took with my add that three hours
felt like I don't know what and we went
through it again
and then we looked at the uh
the uh um what was it the drawings and
all of that so we put in like a 10 hour
day and I'm thinking like all right
like let's get the [ __ ] out of here and
then you looked at me like no we're
gonna go through the animatic one more
time
before and I kind of snapped I was like
are you guys out of your [ __ ] mind
and you guys all just stared at me like
no this is what the process is and
that's what I was sitting there going to
myself like what the [ __ ] did I just
sign up for because my idea was like
dude I'm gonna do this animated show I'm
gonna come with a baseball hat and
[ __ ] yada yada into a microphone and
then just go [ __ ] off and go have a
couple of beers I had no idea and I
remember
um
you Victoria like you guys just didn't
you guys didn't wear out you're like a
fighter in that fifth round you still
had plenty of guests
it's true I think you have I mean I
don't know that's the only way I know
how to do it
um I know gotta make it excellent but
you give this [ __ ] too you know look you
could have easily voiced and bounced and
felt like all right we'll put it
together and we'll see where it lands
but you cared I I remember our final
night of season one when we had the
color and it was another Marathon night
and we looked again and it was like play
it again and we were live time we were
able to tweak and edit right remember I
think we were in Wild West doing it we
had a little system set up and you
finally turned and said okay
we're done and you said no matter what
happens with the show
I'm really proud of what we've done here
and I knew that you felt that way and
was like because we didn't know like
when you launched something you don't
know if it's gonna get in the culture
hit you just don't know and you know we
had limited press Netflix was still new
we were I think one of the first 10
shows yeah Network this was 2015. but
you I saw you kind of release
you were like okay it's done and it's
ready to go and whatever happens happens
and you felt that you were happy and I
felt like in a lot of ways that was kind
of in the early boxes of mission
statements like you were putting a lot
of your personal stuff out there so I
think all of us collaborating you'd be
like look this is you know Bill's Vision
we want him to be happy we're going to
support and push after 10 hours yes a
lot but ultimately like
it made us feel good
that you felt good in a way because it
was sort of like that was part of the
goal well now it obviously went on to do
well and we had five seasons and it
found an audience but even I got one for
you I'm done
some fans sent in today it was up in
Vancouver I saw that you saw that on the
freight train yeah listeners at home on
the freight train some uh some graffiti
artist put uh Rosie and uh Frank Murphy
on the side of this freight train that
thing's going so good just yeah
yeah I thought that was like that
someone gave a [ __ ] enough like that's
like I wish people could understand
like what that feels like we were like
in that room figuring out how to draw
this thing and like you know seven eight
years later somebody's painting on the
side of a train you're like the tattoos
people send the tattoos like they're
permanently putting these characters on
their body I mean that's a pretty good
company too right
well here's the thing dude I cannot wait
to see this movie I'm finally off the
road by Taurus done and uh I think
you'll dig it dude it's fine I'm
definitely gonna I mean obviously do it
I gotta I gotta support you everything
you've done for me but like when I saw
the trailer I was going look at look at
Peter man it was a little he went behind
the scenes and then you pop right back
out and you know that muscle comes right
back it's the fifth Christmas movie now
that I've done
um when you throw an elf and then I did
another one this year Christmas with the
Campbells
um and the two Christmas stories and
Four Christmases
um I'm nervous you were gonna say that
you're the queen of Christmas and I
wanted to let you know that Mariah Carey
has trained I can never take that mantle
yeah don't say that she can sue you
written
oh wow well God bless her that's a title
I will gladly never refer to myself as
you don't have to worry about that bill
I'm not glad I'm a little disappointed I
kind of was one of my goals to be the
queen of Christmas yeah can you imagine
being the lawyer taking that phone call
yeah listen I I want to be Christmas
again I have this idea to Brand myself
the queen of Christmas okay cool no no
no I want to trade market I don't want
anybody else I am the queen of Christmas
can you imagine having to be the guy to
call the people to say you can't say
that anymore like I'm so sorry to inform
you two adults
crack that statement I know and they're
like it's Christmas like I'm just trying
to have a nice Christmas I I'm sorry you
can no longer refer yes as that other
than there's people out there
trademarking their kids names
like nobody else can name your kid this
[ __ ] name it's [ __ ] no that's too
much dude
that's it's
my thing is all I think about is the
lawyers
and it's just like that first they're
probably gonna hang up they laugh and
then they go then they're looking at all
their standard contracts for different
situations and it's like all right we
just gotta look at this kid like he's
the name of a movie or something let's
just make that contract get rid of uh
Jaws three put the kid's name in there
and I think we can uh get out of here by
Friday around midnight oh it's so sad no
I mean there's
there's it gets to a point where it's
exhausting because people have taken my
license I'll walk by a cookie store you
know a bakery or something and I look
down and it's my face on a freaking
cookie in the window and part of you is
tempted to go in and be like man come on
you know and then another part of me is
just like move on but I have some
friends that'll go in and start yelling
at the proprietor like you have to pay a
license for that it'll be me no you
can't do it just something I'm just like
if it was a Starbucks and they put them
all around the [ __ ] country
all right it's fine you know if I walk
in give me a cookie that's a deal we're
done it's easy it's simple
but it's you you do have to you do have
to cut I mean you do have to police it a
little bit though because it can get out
of hand people will start
um I remember they started a beer it is
kind of funny to pick up a cookie with
your face on it and start shouting at
another adult
as you're eating it slowly
counted on me walking by you Bakery did
you it's probably a good way to parent
as well I think your parents are looking
like whoa I went I saw someone who
started a beer
and I had my face on a beer tap and it
was something like you know Ralphie's
Suds or something I don't know what it
was it was some flavor of beer I was
like well that's kind of clever
but you have to monitor a little bit you
even have control of that I mean you
were a kid I mean that's not
control in the sense that you still
control your own likeness right so that
you do but all the crazy merchandising
that this movie has ensued and all the
products that they've made I mean right
think of a movie no one ever ever
imagined ever being able to do it
you know and just my favorite thing is
when you used to tell stories about how
they would show that movie
A Christmas Story 24 hours straight on
one channel and then they would say to
you they'd only pay you for one playing
going like well that was all just one
playing and you're like no man you paid
it like 15 times
I should get and they're like well
nobody watched it 15 times in a row it's
like well did you get paid once for 24
hours of advertising and you no of
course they did yeah every time you sold
a commercial did you get a check sag has
some rule I think that if you play
something multiple times in the day you
only pay reserves within a day so that
was a light bulb moment like oh so
that's why they're running a marathon
because it's basically free and all they
do is collect all the different Revenue
I know but you know what they're
faceless and you're not so then people
it was just going one and above two no
dude you got it you gotta take the good
with the bad it was fun I just had um I
went through a bunch of these kind of
old War Stories did you know I started a
podcast
because
we're only six episodes in but we're
profiling uh um classic Christmas movies
so I hosted with Nick shank we kind of
break down like themes and why these
movies resonate with us
um and I did A Christmas Story and I had
um I had flick and Schwartz and Randy on
and it was kind of awesome because we
were going back through all the
remembrances of doing the original and a
lot of stuff that I had forgotten
because they're in the same boat like
no one's really been financially
compensated going forward so it's sort
of like let's tell some War Stories and
remember
some kind of times we kind of broke down
the flagpole but
um I remember because I was just talking
to the cinematographer of home alone and
he said that they kept Joe Pesci away
from Macaulay Culkin the director did to
not let him get comfortable so anytime
they were in a scene like he would be
able to be scared right if you're
hanging out in the trailer kind of
dispels that and I remember people used
to do that to me and Bob Clark did that
with the bullies they had reminded me
that he didn't really the director
didn't really let us play on set with
him he wanted to keep them like super
scary so you get that kind of organic
fright every time they come around even
a little Stanley Kubrick
kind of oddly yes yeah it was like um
yeah and trying to get reactions on
camera I loved all that old stuff I
remember I think I I think it was on
that one when I had to cry I was pretty
good at crying because I had done enough
movies but every now and then some A.D
would try literally
because they would get frustrated if it
was taking you a minute they're like
look
I got this on good authority we just
killed your dog how do you feel about
that your dog is dead
it's like first of all I was like I
ain't falling for that you know the
business I was two and a half but I'm
like what are you doing are you getting
so nuts you're so desperate to get a kid
to cry that you would go there
yeah I know those were those were the
days man those are abused children those
were the days when you could abuse
children
um I'm gonna go and do a coughing fit
here if I don't
wrap this up here because I don't know
what the I have that [ __ ] RSVP
whatever the [ __ ] that virus is you get
it
well I got tested for Kobe they don't
have anything for that yeah you know
I think it's a conspiracy man
um anyway uh A Christmas Story Christmas
is in theaters now with the great Peter
Billingsley returning with most of the
original class uh cast they rebuilt the
whole town I mean it's it's incredible
and uh I feel really lucky that I have a
wife and two beautiful kids to bring it
to and that it's a family-friendly movie
um I know my daughter's gonna love it I
think my son might be a little too young
but uh I think she's gonna love it gonna
hit it this week and um I'll give you my
little review thank you sir I'm kidding
the great Peterbilt everybody go check
out A Christmas Story Christmas in
theaters now great for fun for all the
family and the kids all right thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday Morning podcast from Monday
December 22nd 2014.
how's it going
[Music]
really that's good
um that's it too one more Monday there's
one more Monday after this one
all right
we're down to our second to last time
out here
before I do this podcast right ah man I
got nothing to talk about this week you
know why because old freckles
is on [ __ ] vacation
all right
I'm not doing [ __ ]
I'm not doing it I'm not doing [ __ ] you
don't wanna [ __ ] with beady
is on vacation
noodle
baby
for vacation
[ __ ] imma kill you
um
I have absolutely nothing to talk about
because I've been in a [ __ ] writer's
room and uh they had a lactic gig and
I've been in the [ __ ] bubble I have
no idea what's going on in the world
right now
other than Sony leaks everybody freaking
out about Sony leaks did you did you
read any no I didn't read any of the
[ __ ] things why would I read that
it's somebody else's email you [ __ ]
weirdo won't you stand outside their
window and rub your dick
you know
you're a piece of [ __ ] if you read any
of those [ __ ] emails that's all I'm
saying okay because be honest with
yourself if somebody stole your [ __ ]
all your [ __ ]
you wouldn't be in trouble
you wouldn't be a little nervous you
don't got a dick pic or a [ __ ] or
something
you didn't look at something weird
right eating trash
the [ __ ] chick won cubicle over
because you want to [ __ ] her and she
won't
so he starts saying she's a lesbian or
she's frigid or some [ __ ] you probably
said it way worse than that
right
now you're going to hold these people
you're going to hold these people
accountable these wonderful people over
at Sony
that make movies for you snot nose
[ __ ] kids to watch so you can go in
the other room and [ __ ] steal a
[ __ ]
20 minutes of sleep
you know maybe go walk out onto your
balcony and [ __ ] hustle little
smoke a little weed
why does that moment happen huh
because of people like Sony
making movies about [ __ ]
stereotypical characters on rugs flying
around the Middle East right
talking planes and talking cars
fat people with no legs talking to
computers
all those [ __ ] movies
it's because of people like them and
what do you do you turn around you find
out that their [ __ ] emails are on the
internet and what do you do you piece of
[ __ ] how do you repay them
for shutting your [ __ ] snot nose kid
up for two and a half [ __ ] hours two
hours whatever
because of those wonderful people over
at Sony you can take your dumbass kid
then only you find cute
prop them up in front of the [ __ ] TV
and he can sit there goddamn catatonic
you know well maybe you got time to go
rub one out
I'll go pull yourself a [ __ ] whiskey
maybe just have a couple of minutes to
yourself and enjoy a piece of toast
how do you repay them you immediately
sit down in the [ __ ] in your computer
and you go and you read their [ __ ]
emails
during the holiday season how dare you
yeah I could give a [ __ ] about all of it
um
I don't understand why they pulled the
[ __ ] movie though
do you really think the al-Qaeda was
going to do that [ __ ] let's just say
they were behind 9 11. who knows at this
point right
that's like you know
who came up with the [ __ ] grilled
cheese sandwich at this point
everybody's claimed responsibility that
was my it was my aunt Harriet
foreign
she lived in Wisconsin or some [ __ ]
[ __ ] right everybody's claimed
[ __ ] responsibility everybody's been
blamed for that from Saddam to Al Qaeda
to your buddy name Fred down the [ __ ]
Street
all right so let's just say that these
guys you know
these [ __ ] 600 people on a jungle gym
half a world away did this [ __ ] right
let's just say they did it
you're telling me
that they're going to go
from knocking down buildings and and
[ __ ] blowing up the Pentagon to
attack at a movie theater
doesn't that seem like anticlimactic
that's it's kind of like as a comedian
you would start with your best joke and
then it just [ __ ] tapers off from
there and then slowly you
you just like
the crowd's just staring at you
I mean I would think their next move
would be something even bigger right
you think right
if murdering innocent people is an art
you'd want to progress
like anybody else does a guitar player
want to be worse than he was the day
before I don't think he does
we got more movie theaters than they
have members in Al Qaeda I don't
understand what the [ __ ] problem is
what are they going to do they're just
going to walk in
they're going to get all those [ __ ]
[ __ ] over here I guess they were just
going to do it to one
I don't know it just seemed like a [ __ ]
move
we just caved
we [ __ ] caved now what
now what what's the next thing they're
gonna [ __ ] threat
oh Jesus am I doing that argument that's
a slippery
you know we can't
um
I don't give a really I don't really
give a [ __ ] about any [ __ ] story in
the news uh uh unless it's some local
guy who did something heroic
if it's it's somebody who saved a
[ __ ] animal or uh
they're talking about what a piece of
[ __ ] Banks and insurance companies are
other than that I don't I don't care
I don't care I don't make the
environment I'm over the environment
we're gonna destroy it
you know
people are going to sit there and deny
that we have any sort of effect on the
climate of this [ __ ] planet yeah why
would we why would we we do we we live
on land and we've ruined the oceans
how could we ever affect the climate
there's over one trillion pieces of
[ __ ] plastic in the goddamn ocean
we live on the land people how does that
happen
is there a shark [ __ ] up your
backyard I don't think there is
we're essentially the worst [ __ ]
thing on the planet and the coolest
thing you know what I mean
because we have an inventions
as far as I know no other animal on this
planet has ever invented anything
not a [ __ ] thing
you know we get all like you get all
excited when you see your dog use his
hands as like a pair of Paws to hold a
[ __ ] bone look at his door
hey
right
we can make a robot dog at this point
you hear that Cleo you're obsolete
um
yeah I don't know I don't even know any
anything what the [ __ ] is going on but
you know something the next time
somebody's
account gets hacked why don't you have a
little bit of empathy going like hey you
know I wouldn't like that to happen to
me
and just leave him the [ __ ] alone who
gives a [ __ ]
they're talking [ __ ] about different
[ __ ] people of course they are that's
what people do that's what everybody
does
me an old jota Rosa we get on the phone
sometimes we'll call another [ __ ]
comedian and all three of us will just
sit there first we start off we trash
each other and then the circle just gets
bigger and bigger
start trashing other people we know and
sometimes we're trashing somebody so
well we actually call that person up
because we don't want them to miss it
laughs
um anyways who gives a [ __ ] the Sony
leaks acting like somebody broke into
the [ __ ] pentagon
um
anyways this is the Monday morning
podcast uh
uh I'm [ __ ] psyched
I'm psyched but downstairs in my house
is basically finished they got a couple
of knick-knack things at this point I'm
over we actually moved in
to the downstairs area oh my God I was
gonna [ __ ]
I don't know what I was gonna do I was
gonna take a bucket of water and dump it
over my wife's head the other day right
she wants to move the [ __ ] bed
downstairs okay but the workers still
have to come here in the morning they
got to do a little touch up paint they
gotta [ __ ] fix this and that's a
little off
you know sand this thing down
and she's all hot to try to get the
goddamn bed downstairs
all right and I get it I get it I
understand
when a man pays for a house
it's not his house it's the woman's
house it's a giant dollhouse and they're
gonna [ __ ] decorate it and they
already knew what they were going to put
in the [ __ ] thing when they were like
seven years old
okay and I gave into that [ __ ] I'm like
can't find find whatever you know go
nuts go nuts because someday I'm going
to redo that [ __ ] garage
okay I want to redo that [ __ ] Grudge
I'm gonna add a second floor to it and
I'm gonna only I will have keys to it
and uh whenever I'm sick of you I'm just
gonna [ __ ] go in there I'm sick of
[ __ ] dreaming about a house that has
a garage that's separate from the house
I kind of have that
in a way I'll just build a [ __ ]
upstairs
and I'll just say you are not allowed up
there
you know what do you think she's gonna
do do you think she can actually leave
it alone she won't
she wants so anyways she wants to bring
the bed downstairs
it's the only bed we have in the [ __ ]
house
right we had a guest bed but it was out
in the garage and the rain came down and
[ __ ] up the mattress so we don't have
all we have is a box spring upstairs
whatever she gets the [ __ ] people to
put the goddamn bed there so we go
downstairs all right both of us had gone
out the night before we were out till 2
30 in the [ __ ] morning now we're
sleeping downstairs and who shows up at
seven in the morning the [ __ ] workers
so now we gotta get up
we could have kept sleeping if we were
upstairs so we get up
right we get up
and we walk upstairs and I'm not saying
[ __ ] and we go upstairs the only place
to sleep is the [ __ ] couch and she
goes and she just [ __ ] lays down
right on the goddamn couch and
immediately goes to sleep and I'm like
where the [ __ ] am I supposed to sleep
she mumbled something and went back to
sleep so I had to grab two cushions off
the back of the couch walk in and
[ __ ] build like a mini bed on top of
this [ __ ] box spring and I went in
there and I slept
and oh was I in a [ __ ] mood that day
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
you know but my wife is the [ __ ]
what's she smarter smart as hell because
afterwards when she asked me while I was
being so snippy when I explained the
scenario
she apologized and it was sincere and
she really meant it
so then I was just left with this
[ __ ] anger I had nothing to do with
right so I just went over my dog and I
just put it in a headlock right
I just started [ __ ] school I'm
kidding
um
anyways let's read some [ __ ]
advertising here for this week
bought my Christmas tree late
yeah went down there it's pretty good
though the good people they didn't have
a bunch of Charlie Brown Christmas trees
even though I like those ones I always
feel bad for more I just think the
ornaments look better when there's less
branches
instead of that [ __ ]
shrub shaped like a ghost that most
Christmas trees are
I actually bought a Christmas tree that
I'm taller than
I just bought a little one
you know my truck's still in storage
because those workers still have their
[ __ ] in the garage is this slowly
[ __ ] you know they're leaving my
house the way we're leaving Afghanistan
you know one tank at a time
and um
I don't know so I usually just you know
go out and get a full-size [ __ ] tree
and I just throw in the back of my truck
and I drive down the street like I'm a
man and I know how to fix things you
know
but uh this year all I had was the Prius
so what am I going to do stick a giant
[ __ ] Tree on there I'm not just give
me a precise Christmas tree
I could actually bully my Christmas tree
I could walk up to it and take all the
ornaments and it wouldn't do anything
it'd just stare at the [ __ ]
floorboards it's kind of sad
and then I went this is our latest start
I got then I bought what are they called
poinsettias those [ __ ] red flowers
bought them at the grocery store I
bought the two last ones looking like a
boat they are all shriveled up looking
like a junkie just sort of nodding off
or whatever
and uh that's it threw some bulbs on it
put those [ __ ] flowers on either side
of the fireplace and it's over
it's Christmas time
so I do it
I'm sorry guys I don't [ __ ] have
anything you know what I have I have
some information for you uh the Patrice
O'Neill benefit everybody
slowly but surely
this benefit is going to [ __ ] sell
out
this is always a [ __ ] every goddamn
year you know hyping this thing around
the holidays I'd love to get tickets but
I have to buy a scarf from my aunt
um all right Patrice O'Neal benefit the
third annual Patrice O'Neal Comedy
benefit is Wednesday February 11 2015 at
7 pm at the city center 131 West 55th
Street between 6th and 7th Ave uh the
lineup in alphabetical order Ben Bailey
Bill Burr Colin Quinn Dave Attell
Hannibal Burris Jim florenty Jim Norton
Michael Che and Rich Voss
what the [ __ ] else you got to get a show
like that tickets can be purchased the
following away Falling Away online at
www.nycitycenter.org
or by calling
212-581-1212 makes a great [ __ ]
Christmas gift
and uh really helps us do a wonderful
thing
for the great Patrice O'Neal
um
and whatever the box office window is
131 West 55th Street between 6th and 7th
Ave
and while I'm at it
um if you guys are fans of the Rose Bowl
and you live in the Lorraine
is it Lorraine Ohio Lorraine Catholic
what's the name of the school that Jason
law had went to uh Rose Bowl Legend
and Grill Master
Jason lawhead is going to be performing
a theater show this is a very unique
show in Lorraine Ohio
and his Hall of Fame
uh high school basketball coach father
is going to be opening up telling
stories
I don't think I've ever seen a father
open up for his son
at a stand-up show much less a Hall of
Fame basketball coach who's going to be
telling stories and uh
a couple years ago we did that bus tour
through the South uh he came along with
us and it just really one of the most
amazing human beings I ever met
uh I think that's December 27th we'll
have all that information if you want to
go once again that that also makes a
great Christmas gift there
um
so
I haven't been doing [ __ ] you know what
you know what I do whenever the downtime
comes around again as I [ __ ] um
I get into cooking speaking of Jason
lawhead and last night for the first
time ever I usually am a grill guy
and pork chops I always broiled them
because that's how I learned
how to make them when I was a kid you
just broil them I'm just gonna pause
here and wait for all the Foodies to be
like oh my God you know
um I actually pan seared
pan-seared these [ __ ] pork chops last
night and they were [ __ ] delicious
browned them up on both sides
and a skillet right and then I took the
skillet and I stuck it in the oven at
400 degrees
for like another five six minutes
probably should have had him in there
for seven they were pretty thick
and uh took those [ __ ] out
and I had this magazine
that taught you how to do a uh it's
called a butter bath
I know I know I'm putting on weight here
you just drop some butter into the
skillet afterwards you don't have to
have it on heat it's been in the [ __ ]
oven so it's already hot right you just
drop it in there and you throw in some
Sage fresh Sage thyme and uh some
Rosemary
a couple of [ __ ] little garlic uh
a lot of Knuckles whatever the [ __ ] you
call those things
and you let that once the bubble bubbles
and the butter foam up you just spoon it
up and you drop it on the [ __ ] pork
chop forget it go [ __ ] yourself then you
take the pork chop and whoever you
cooked it for you slap them in the face
with you say eat that [ __ ] and don't
wipe the grease off your face or I'll
never cook for you again I'll tell you
they'll sit there and read that whole
[ __ ] thing with a smile on their face
and grease with rosemary in it right on
the side of their face and they won't
feel humiliated at all
that's a true story
that's what I did last night let's let's
let me just read some [ __ ]
advertisement before this whole goddamn
podcast goes off the rails okay
right there
um what do we got here
I actually don't have this at my
fingertips anymore because I had to
[ __ ] get a new operating system and
then like the notes thing where I I
write my uh ideas or whatever I have to
sign up for some [ __ ] they want all this
[ __ ] information
[ __ ] weirdos
all right here we go Sherry's Berries
everybody
don't get your Tinsel in a tangle
Christmas is this Thursday have you
checked everyone off your list don't
sweat it I can help avoid stressing out
about what last minute gift to get
Cherries Berries is a unique gift that
is sure to be a hit and it's just a
click away
with only if you're really stressing
about a gift I don't think oh I know
I'll get them chocolate strawberries
this is the gift you give somebody that
you got to get them a gift just to show
you making a [ __ ] effort all right
Sherry's Berries don't don't get don't
get beside yourself
all right oh [ __ ] I forgot to get my
mother a gift I think I'll get a
chocolate covered strawberries that's
your [ __ ] disown you this is a gift
you get that broad you're banging but
you're not gonna commit to the
relationship all right with only one day
left to shop
your time is limited
give this incredible delicious gift and
skip the crowds all together by Cherries
Berries in seconds
um we got freshly dipped strawberries
some Shari's Berries starting in 1999
you can double those berries
right for only ten dollars more
Christmas is in three days and we can
still guarantee the delivery by
Christmas you just need my coat to take
advantage of the deal Burr b-u-r-r
all right additional copy points
describe the berries in your own words
try using advertising adjectives like
decadent fresh juicy sweet and
irresistible
all right I'll use all of them Sherry
let me tell you something these decadent
fresh juicy sweet chocolate covered
strawberries they are irresistible
choose berries dipped and tempting white
milk and dark chocolatey goodness
that's the kind of sentence this makes
me hate fat people is it really tempting
oh God
what's the matter oh those [ __ ]
strawberries on the corner man
look at me man top wall right but we get
the [ __ ] point what am I doing here
visit berries.com spell out the word
berries
b-e-r-r-i-e-s.com click on the
microphone in the top right hand corner
and type in burb urr it's the perfect
gift without any hassle man this
Christmas
yeah it is the perfect gift who the [ __ ]
wants to go to a store you know I wanted
to go buy some workout clothes for my
wife so I went down to the Nike store
and when I showed up the other day on a
Saturday right before Christmas there
was a line of [ __ ] people out the
store and I'm thinking like oh this has
to be those sneaker heads right this guy
they're they're reissuing uh [ __ ]
Patrick Ewing's jock strap and all these
guys all the [ __ ] dope I gotta get it
right so I figure I could just walk all
around him but I was stopped at a red
light and I looked at everybody in line
and it was all different aged people
older people and [ __ ] and I was like oh
my God that's the line to get in the
store
that looks like somebody's not getting
work out close and no that wasn't going
to be the main gift that was just one of
those things you know to fill out the
area around the tree
sweatpants are great it takes up space
they're easy to wrap
all right all right how you like that
guys I have read those pretty good I
think I read those
pretty [ __ ] good
all right let's talk some [ __ ] a
little bit of football this week
Patriots Jets
have you ever seen an ugly or win
good Lord that was an ugly [ __ ] game
um I actually think the Jets should have
won that game am I on my [ __ ] mind
and Gino Smith should not be blamed for
both of those sacks the second one and
he said hike there was a guy in his face
but that the first one
that took him out of field goal range to
the point the guy had to kick it low and
Vince Wilfork a [ __ ] 350 pound guy
somehow blocked a field goal
um
I would blame him on that one but I'll
tell you who I wouldn't blame I wouldn't
blame Rex Ryan I as much as I think that
guy
uh has no class
and then when he gets called on it he
acts like a baby
you know he talks all kinds of [ __ ] and
then when they lose he's like yo people
are going to criticize this team but
they have no right to yeah they do they
do you talked a bunch of [ __ ] and said
you were going to win the whole thing
and then you didn't you set yourself up
for the criticism
um but I still think he's a [ __ ]
great coach and I don't think that
that's the problem with that team
when he had the players he got him to
the uh AF East AFC not the AFC East the
[ __ ] AFC Championship Game Jesus bill
even watch the sport but uh sometimes
they just make a change because they
feel like it quiets the fan base
they just [ __ ] Lop somebody's head
off but I think that that would be a
[ __ ] mistake as much as I was I would
love to see that guy I don't want to see
him lose his job like maybe lose the
Jets job and then go over to the NFC I
don't [ __ ] see that guy anymore he
drives me up the [ __ ] wall like when
Brady threw that pick and then he's
running on the field
[ __ ] pumping his fist looking like
some loser at the track
because his dog finally came in you know
but I don't [ __ ] know I just he yeah
I I like the guy but he just you know he
talks all that [ __ ] and then when it's
and then when he has a bad team he
[ __ ] clams up and acts like he
learned the lesson do you honestly think
if Rex Ryan gets another loaded team
that he's not gonna start talking [ __ ]
again
eating Bundt Cakes blowing out those
stitches
um
all right
let me pull me plow ahead here and then
I'm gonna say my Bill Burr's Super Bowl
pick stand up comedian never played
organized football beyond the third
grades
Bill Burr his Super Bowl picked up
[Music]
suck my [ __ ] dick
um I'm taking Seattle Seahawks
I'm taking I know that's not a bold pick
but I I gotta tell you something I've
never been more wrong about a coach than
Pete Carroll I remember Pete Carroll
who's with the Patriots he followed Bill
Parcells he comes in he's the little
pretty boy he's wearing Dockers they
make a good play he goes whoa
I thought the guy was soft and then when
he went to college and he won a chance
he rebuilt the USC program doing what
you do
got caught and ran out the back door
when the Wolves started coming around I
don't give a [ __ ] he did what people do
at division one to win and the guy
[ __ ] won and I was like
he's a college coach he's not a pro
coach then he [ __ ] goes to Seattle
where the [ __ ] was Seattle where the
[ __ ] with the Seattle Seahawks
before Pete Carroll
where were they
huh
nowhere
it's a bunch of Starbucks Starbucks
drinking douchebags wearing bergenstocks
and those rain ponchos
just standing around in the rain
they were all sad Seattle's going
nowhere a lot of people don't realize
this that's why Kurt Cobain killed
himself
wasn't the [ __ ] ulcer it wasn't the
demons
he was just sick of rooting for the
Mariners and the Seahawks
so Pete Carroll goes in there with a fan
base is literally suicidal and within
five years they get a [ __ ] Super Bowl
that's hard enough to do but the hardest
[ __ ] thing to do I think as a Kevin
never coached at any [ __ ] level
I think the hardest [ __ ] thing to do
is after you win a championship is to
come out the next year and get your team
hungry again to do it again
you know
that [ __ ] Pat Riley did
okay the [ __ ] Bill Belichick did like
there's very few people that can
motivate
Chuck Knoll did it twice to get them
hungry again [ __ ] Seattle
like they're [ __ ] defense I I is
I don't know what to say about like I I
think
if they somehow obviously if they get
[ __ ] home field events I just don't
see anybody stopping them and I
certainly think that the the Super Bowl
champion is going to be coming out of
the NFC and I got a feeling that the
Patriots we get home field
all right we got a chance to go to the
Super Bowl again but we don't have
I mean anything can happen all right
this is me just speaking logically when
I watch both teams I don't think that we
have a shot against those guys
um but as a Patriots fan
I say [ __ ] the Seahawks
all right
I I can't even say that I mean I don't
know what the what are we gonna do
what what the [ __ ] do we got you know
we're doing well in the AFC I don't know
why it always gets like this it always
gets really unbalanced like [ __ ] in
the beginning like the NFC one like the
first
I don't know how many [ __ ]
championships Super Bowls and then the
AFC one on this [ __ ] run where we won
like
well [ __ ] Bill you're a nerd you should
know
it went Steelers Steelers Raiders 49ers
won one
in 81.
82 was the Redskins
83
was the
Raiders
and it was 49ers oh it was the NFC that
went on the Run
is that what it was
and the Bears
that's right that's right then the NFC
went on a run AFC was on a run and then
NFC went on a run
and then when AFC now NFC again I don't
know why it always just gets like it
always seems like
like 60 or 70 percent of the NFL seasons
either the AFC Championship or the NFC
Championship Game everybody's going you
know who's getting who this is the
[ __ ] Super Bowl
and then the Super Bowl becomes a
blowout all those [ __ ] years it was a
blowout the Broncos lost
to the Giants that wasn't all right one
then they got smoked by the [ __ ]
Redskins after going up 14 to nothing
then 49ers Bengals was great and then
Broncos got raped
[ __ ] raped oh and the Patriots got
raped by the Bears before all that
[ __ ] Super Bowl 20 and the [ __ ]
Broncos got raped 55 to something by the
49ers
it's been a close game with the bills
Giants won then the Redskins handled the
bills and then the bills got raped twice
and a Ralph by the [ __ ] Cowboys
and was it 49ers charges
Jesus Christ
that was like a bad Pay-Per-View fight
you know
um I know what I'm talking about I just
think the Seahawks are uh I think
they're too good and that [ __ ] Wilson
kid that guy is the next guy
I think he's the next guy even Beyond uh
it might be Andrew Luck in the AFC even
though he's having a [ __ ] but last
yesterday it wasn't his fault Jesus
Christ one guy drops a pass and they all
[ __ ] do it that Cowboys Colts game
reminded me of the Super Bowl last year
one bad play in the first series of
downs and they never got it back just
all went off the [ __ ] rails
[ __ ] punch it through that pass look
like a Robert Parish foul shot right in
the guy's hands did he looked like me
out there
all right
what am I talking about here let's um
let's move on here let's get to some
questions for this week how far into the
podcast are we 32 [ __ ] minutes O.J
Simpson uh
you know what I'm gonna go off the rails
here
and I'm going to read one for my other
account that I found actually founded
I thought we didn't have enough
questions this week so occasionally I'll
dip into my other [ __ ] account here
to see what we got
come on me you old ass [ __ ] computer
so [ __ ] slow here all right dear
Billy Costanza
uh recently
what is that Jason uh Alexander [ __ ]
because I'm bald and I yell uh recently
I was in Boston for work and decided to
visit a good old friend of mine from
back in the day while I was visiting I
happened to run into his younger sister
who was my age nothing creepy
in high school I was the bad boy Class
Clown ah gee what were you in Greece
[ __ ] jerk off
picture do you want a leather jacket
I'll go over here
um
I love all those singing jerk offs like
the people thought that they [ __ ]
built that car
they were in the Glee Club
all right it's the burnouts the burnouts
down the hall and [ __ ] wood shop and
the power mechanics they could do
something like that anyways and she was
then you know I've never seen Grace
I've never seen it whenever I turn it on
they're always racing in the in the LA
River
and I think one time I saw the ending
but uh
never seen it but I've seen all of
Greece too
and when I saw it I enjoyed it
um all right plowing ahead here in high
school I was the bad boy class clown man
you know me man I was a rebel
do you have a raccoon tail hanging from
the antenna your car they are [ __ ]
Shifty and she was the nerdy anti-social
flat-chested type I always knew she had
a thing for me but I was too busy
chasing all the who was over there
well Bill it turns out she's become
quite the young lady
since then master's degree great
corporate gig a great rack and then he
writes a great rack
and she happens to be single she
insisted she show me you know so [ __ ]
funny is the way guys look at women
I wonder if women do that they just
don't admit it you know turns out you
know it turns out you know he's got a
strong jaw
a great job
a [ __ ] fat cat like a a big wad what
would you say
a nice [ __ ]
I'm literally sitting here and [ __ ]
acting like I'm grabbing dick and balls
right now trying to think of the [ __ ]
word I don't know what the [ __ ] they
would say do you guys ever do that
um anyways well it turns out she became
quite the young lady blah blah blah and
she happens to be single she insisted
she show me around town all you know all
the touristy [ __ ] so we exchanged
numbers
Donna
later that day when I got back to my
hotel we started texting
now we no big deal just catch up now
just catching up okay how you been how's
the family blah blah blah then we start
talking on the phone all right and
pretty soon your dick's up I thought
what she had for me in high school was
ancient history but no the conversation
soon took a turn and got romantic and he
writes yo Jesus so we made plans to meet
for the next day for lunch the next day
hanging out with my buddy I casually
brought up if he would have a problem
with me dating his sister he insisted he
had no problem with it
hey you know what dude I thought you
were a piece of [ __ ]
there you go all right you
such a weird thing I I could never ask
my friend you mind if I date your sister
you mean what you mind if I if you're if
you [ __ ] my sister yeah I do
you better marry her you son of a [ __ ]
so he's like okay great so I take her to
lunch
we do all the touristy stuff then I took
her back to her place while in the
parking lot at her place she is getting
out of my car
and I go to give her a hug good night
this is when the hog turned into into a
kiss
she got back in my car and we made out
really hardcore bill I was surprised at
how aggressive she was being all nerdy
as she was
why do people think nerdy women don't
have needs too
you know
they're just a little introverted
all you got to do is give him the green
light
you know open the [ __ ] door
um blah blah blah
where the hell was I I was surprised how
aggressive she was she asked um I was
surprised how aggressive she was being
all nerdy as she was but there was
something oddly sexy about it
uh she asked to to ditch her place and
go back to my hotel oh [ __ ] Jesus Christ
dude Jesus
so I say okay cool on the way there I
started having second thoughts I thought
things might be moving too fast I know I
know what a [ __ ] no dude it's actually
a very [ __ ]
it's a mature choice there
you got other women that you just
banging this is this is not somebody you
can just discard this is your friend's
sister you're going to run into her
again you gotta go easy on this one
it's a [ __ ] ticking time bomb
so anyways we go back to my room nothing
happened
I cooled it off intentionally we had a
few drinks talk joked around while she
laid on my bed this is when I noticed
that she laughed exactly like my buddy
her brother oh no
the more she laughed the more it's
bothering me needless to say that was
the end of the night
a makeout session and a few drinks and
some laughs so here's my question bill I
think this girl is perfect for me she's
smart educated gorgeous girl but how can
I get over that laugh
all I could do was picture her brother
and nothing kills the mood more than
that for me am I being a dick for
thinking about passing up this girl or
is there something here Bill thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself
um
I don't know if there's something there
you got to tell me but as far as an
outsider looking in yeah you can't be
with that girl
you're gonna end up [ __ ] your friend
I'm joking
um
no I know what you mean I remember there
was a buddy of mine
I had and his sister looked exactly like
him with long hair
I mean it was like it was uncanny how
much they looked like each other and you
know
she was a nice person everything but it
was it was my friend in Drag
and you know so much of a relationship
keeping it going is if you can make each
other laugh and if every time she
[ __ ] laughs
you got to break up with one one of the
two I don't know you break up with you
you can't be friends with him anymore
he's got to be with her long enough that
that laugh becomes her laugh
I don't know do you know what it really
comes down to is how freaked out you are
by it
you know
I mean every guy's had this you meet a
girl in the bar and you're attracted to
her and then she has the same name as
your mother it's like over
over
it's over
done deal can't do it why what's the
matter I can't tell you
can't tell you see you later sweetheart
see you later
you are trapped you're trampling on
sacred ground there sweetheart
get it what's your middle name
because I want to address you by your
name when I say to get the [ __ ] out of
my face
um I don't know what you do there buddy
I mean if you actually feel like this
there's something there beyond the fact
that you want to just bang her
which I don't think you have a problem
finding women to bang so maybe you do
think of something about her I don't
know
uh that's going to be your that would
have to be your choice
um
just personally personally speaking
I don't know if I met the girl that I
thought was you know the one I'm
supposed to be with
and she laughed like my best friend of
oh my God there's seven billion people
on the planet you can't find some woman
to [ __ ] that doesn't laugh like your
friend
ah Jesus you know I'm not good at advice
today
that even sounded ignorant to me
could hear all the [ __ ] women go oh
God he's so [ __ ] stupid
um
all right let's go back to this one dear
Billy Costanza recently I was in Boston
for work and I decided to visit a good
old oh wait a minute what the [ __ ] is
this
oh wait a minute oh I copied and pasted
it I'm a dummy all right threats on your
comedy dear Bill if Kim Jong-il or the
dictator of any country had a problem
with your comedy and strongly suggested
or threatened you to never do a
particular bit again would you stop
doing that bit
um not in the United States
I wouldn't not in Canada not in an
Allied country but you know
if I went over to Asia I would be I'd be
a little uh I don't know
probably even if I was in China
as far as I know they get along with
Korea pretty well
don't they
so they're not really looking at any
Shifty Korean type of dude coming into
town I would be a little bit nervous I
mean [ __ ] that guy like feeds he fed
his uncle
to to wild dogs
the guy was like naked and he just
watched him [ __ ] you know
basically Maul the guy to death and then
eat them
yeah I would definitely be [ __ ]
nervous
um would I stop doing the bit
no I don't think I would stop doing the
bit
uh but you know what these dates I have
coming up going to like Singapore and
Hong Kong and [ __ ] like that I would
definitely be I would not do it in those
countries
you know
the [ __ ] am I Chuck Norris was his Delta
Force yeah I don't give a [ __ ] but I
mean if you're basically saying
I don't know I don't know why they did
that I guess I understand it on one
level because God forbid what if some
[ __ ] copycat Maniac actually went in
and did something
the amount of money that they would have
got sued
and who's getting who they don't make
the money that they make that they used
to make in movies anymore because you
guys all [ __ ] steal them
um so I don't think that they could
handle
um putting out a [ __ ] movie and then
people get blown up or whatever gets
shot up or some [ __ ] and then they have
to to pay all the uh
all the relatives so I guess I
understand it but it's um
you know what's weird is if
why do they make it public
you know what I mean like they they
should have made the Wikileaks or any of
that [ __ ] like
they shouldn't even cover it on the news
because I would have never known like if
they leaked them out I never wouldn't
know
I never would I wouldn't [ __ ] I would
have had no idea the reason why I knew
is because other people told me and I
and the [ __ ] news just you know
let's go about your business who gives a
[ __ ]
so then when they're making these
threats uh we're gonna do this once they
make the threat I guess yeah you can't
back down or that gives them power so I
guess I'd have to do the bit unless
I'm over on this side of the world and
I'm you know I'm not saying [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] get kidnapped
have them do God knows what you know I
see what they do to the Dolphins over
there what the [ __ ] are they gonna do to
me
um all right Christmas baking dear Billy
Dough Boy uh what's happening in the
Burr kitchen this year will you be
baking one of your famous breads or pies
should we expect any pictures on Twitter
of your Creations I actually sent out a
picture of the uh the pan-seared
um
uh pork chops technically if you bake a
bread your house becomes a gingerbread
house hey now
oh Jesus
you know some of you guys are really
funny and then other you guys you guys
write like those jokes that you used to
see on the match game and everybody
would [ __ ] laugh like it was
hilarious
Charles Nelson Reilly
um
I gotta be honest with you uh
underrated pan searing a piece of meat
it's [ __ ] incredible
you pan sear that [ __ ] and then you
baked bake it the rest of the way
through in the oven you take it out give
it a little butter bath go [ __ ] yourself
I got another uh recipe for uh I had a
pan sear a New York strip and if you
ever told me that I was gonna put a
[ __ ] New York strip
in a goddamn pan
and sear it I would say get the [ __ ]
away from me you're a communist
I know what the [ __ ] that means but
whatever I'd say get the [ __ ] away from
me but now after
how unbelievable that pork chop tasted
juicy is goddamn Health
um
I'm all about it
during the Christmas break here I'm
gonna up my pan searing game here
um you know as awesome as I went down to
the local butcher right we got a great
[ __ ] butcher in our neighborhood and
um I went over there and I put in the
order for the [ __ ] Rose Bowl I'm so
goddamn psyched
this year we're doing uh
we're doing some ribs we got the burgers
lawhead's gonna make the [ __ ] omelets
you know what's funny I actually texted
law I had a picture of the uh
the pan seared uh pork chops that I had
and I said that uh
I texted him because he's like the
[ __ ] cook at the thing and I said
just to let you know your backup is
taking some snaps during practice like
I'm breathing down his [ __ ] neck
um I could never be a better cook than
that guy that guy's [ __ ] unbelievable
but um yeah I'm gonna be making a pie
this week
um
I made some more pumpkin bread because
it's a [ __ ] joke to make now at this
point I love it made it for two more
people and I just I drive around La and
I just dropping it off like a brick of
weed
and um
yeah I like doing it in fact you know
what I might make a [ __ ] pie today
just for the [ __ ] of it just because I
haven't made one I didn't make one over
Thanksgiving because the [ __ ]
construction was going on I don't I
don't want to forget how to make the
[ __ ] pie crust now remember people
you don't want to fully mix
all right whatever you're shortening and
everything with the flour you want to
get it where it's just mixed where it's
crumpled because then when you roll it
out as you're rolling the [ __ ] thing
out in the crust that's when
the rest of the mixing happens if you
already have it fully mixed and then you
roll it out you're going to have a tough
crust and that's one to grow on all
right
Christmas gift dilemma
hey old Billy Boy Billy Boy Billy Boy
Billy boy wait let me do the rest of the
[ __ ] advertising here real quick
oh go [ __ ] yourself
you said verbatim all right I'm gonna do
Cheyenne um
all right I tell you about the lady I
saw yelling at that person in the
7-Eleven
I know what happened I walked in and
this [ __ ] lady was yelling at the
7-Eleven guy right and I could tell by
his energy he was right
because he's just still got this sort of
smile like all right lady all right all
right and she's [ __ ] flipping out you
don't touch me you don't pull that out
of my hand he's like all right and she's
getting towards the door and she's
cursing around everything and he goes
all right have a nice night you have a
nice night she just goes [ __ ]
[ __ ] in your mouth
[ __ ] in your mouth you didn't mean
that
I never heard it said that way
[ __ ] in your mouth
um all right Christmas baking all right
did I answer that one yet yeah I did
um Christmas you know what I wanted I'm
gonna do a [ __ ] prime rib
prime rib dinner
popovers and some other [ __ ] [ __ ]
some sort of greens
[ __ ] throw that down with a giant
Goblet of wine
and just start snoring in the corner
like I [ __ ] accomplished something
that'd be a great way to do it
hey you know what's you know what's
[ __ ] uh what are you doing Cleo
huh come here
come here buddy
once in a while you gotta pet your dog
even though you're doing something else
come here
what's going on huh
what's up buddy
gonna go for a hike later [ __ ]
underrated
scratching your dog
on its neck under the collar
a lot of people forget this spot
it's a funny [ __ ] ever the second you do
it they extend their face and they have
a look of satisfaction in their eyes you
wish you could as a human being
experience whatever the [ __ ] it is that
they're experiencing
[ __ ] dog's face right now he's like
oh
all right get out of here
all right
you [ __ ] machine you
um oh when I was done with the pork chop
last night I went out and rinsed the
thing off because my dog has a sensitive
stomach if there's any spices on it she
[ __ ] gets this gets the runs
but uh rinse the whole [ __ ] hey get over
there and lay down
get going
get back over there and lay down
where you going all the doors are closed
get over there and lay down
um
rinsed off the bone actually my wife did
it why am I taking credit she's the one
who did it I didn't have the balls too
because because I take her for a walk
and I have to clean up the [ __ ] [ __ ]
show literally
she's like no I'll I'll
wash it all off the [ __ ] Joy
of a dog when you give it a [ __ ] bone
it's unbelievable
you [ __ ] throw it down they walk
around it tail wagon they just can't
[ __ ] believe it they're so goddamn
stuff you get I give the same can of dog
food
every goddamn night every morning and it
will sit down
but it's just eating the same [ __ ] just
to get that [ __ ] break
unbelievable all right sorry Christmas
gift dilemma
Hey Oh Billy boy my fiance and I are big
fans of your work well thank you very
much I am ready to ask you if you could
tell him Merry Christmas for me on your
podcast I don't have a lot of money to
get him anything this year no
are you the [ __ ] couple from uh the
Bon Jovi song Johnny used to work on the
dog
you just bet on strike he's down all his
luck it's tough
so tough why the [ __ ] was Bon Jovi
sitting in the box with Robert Kraft
applauding a Jet's loss isn't he from
New Jersey we gotta hold on to what we
got
I own arena football and it's not so
great
maybe if I hang out with Bobby Kraft I
can buy the bills I'll give it a shot
sorry
um
so you don't have a lot of money okay I
don't have any money
uh to get him anything this year because
I am working hard and trying to make a
living in theater
he's incredibly supportive of my career
and does everything he can to help me
and make me happy this year I have been
trying to think of something I could do
that was special for him
uh this is where you come in I was
wondering if you could take a few
seconds on the podcast to say Merry
[ __ ] Christmas
to Drew
from Marcy
oh to Drew from Marcy I thought Marcy
was the name of the town so [ __ ]
Marcy what
uh she loves you more than anything in
the world and thinks everything uh
thanks you for everything you have done
for her she can't wait all right so
wait a minute
she loves you I thought this is from
this is from a dude Merry Christmas to
Drew from Marcy
I'm all [ __ ] turned around here
he is incredibly
somebody she wrote he loves you she
loves you no he loves me right
I'm just going to say what you said hey
Merry [ __ ] Christmas Drew
you [ __ ]
I hope you have a 2015 that's uh I don't
know Twinkle Toes I hope you booked
something a bunch of jobs and you become
famous and now you have your own podcast
and everything works out for you stick
with Marcy she seems like a wonderful
woman there you go did that warm you
[ __ ] heart
all right flying a Billy Bob first of
all love the special and can't wait for
f is for family hey everybody I got to
tell you guys
um what you guys have been doing of
tweeting and Facebooking and talking
about my special
um is is unbelievable like a lot of new
fans that I've gotten and all that type
of [ __ ] so I do not take that for
granted
um thank you to everybody who's been
doing that I really appreciate it
um that is all anyways
um and I can't wait for f is for family
you know what neither can I
I did the last
um records
you know for the first six of them
uh Nia took this great picture too I
should re I should tweet it out but um
I did uh
we just had a [ __ ] blast it's the
most fun [ __ ] job I've ever had
and I I really think that this show is
I'm going a little Rex Ryan here I think
if we [ __ ] if we don't drop the ball
this thing is gonna be [ __ ] hilarious
um
yeah it's been it's been [ __ ]
ridiculous ah [ __ ] I gotta wait a year
it's [ __ ] brutal okay I wish it was
coming out tomorrow anyway secondly
congrats on the helicopter training I
had a suspicion you were doing some kind
of training or something because every
time I hear you talk about the
atmosphere and [ __ ] you've started
sounding less and less like an idiot
that was my favorite part of ground
school was the weather uh what is your
favorite thing about flying
and you need to cross over to the dark
side and get your fixed Wing certificate
for all you other people out there
that's means to just fly an airplane
that's fixed Wing as in the wing is
fixed
opposed to a helicopter where it's
spinning around okay and he goes I fly
private jets and I'm a flight instructor
out here in La let's get you and your
wife in something you guys can travel in
dude I love the fact that you think that
I could ever afford something like those
things are like [ __ ] a zillion
dollars
um now with your ADHD and your dyslexia
I'm sure you've botched reading this
email so go [ __ ] yourself
um
that's uh I don't know man I would
fly in a jet that's got to be [ __ ]
unbelievable
um what do I like most about flying
um
I'll tell you yesterday was the first
day I actually felt like one
with the machine like I actually you
know it's kind of like
when you have to stop thinking about
driving and you can just sort of feel
the car
you know you've just done it enough that
you've just sort of [ __ ] it's like
you share in the same brain I finally I
hadn't flown in a minute because I was
all busy and um
but I was thinking about it a lot as
crazy as that sounds I was thinking
about different scenarios and then the
inputs you know
and uh
I flew great I and my favorite you know
my favorite [ __ ] part about flying a
helicopter is uh Auto rotations
um and when I get my license I'm taking
the advanced
auto rotation class where you got to
take it all the way down to the ground
and for those of you people don't know
that's like if you had engine failure
and like many people I also felt
that if the engine failed on a
helicopter you were [ __ ] and you just
fell out of the sky you don't
it's actually safer
I think anyways then fixed wing
because of the house
basically with a fixed Wing you know
you have to the how fast you still have
to be going when you land
you know and if you're not on a [ __ ]
road and it's a goddamn field and
there's tree stumps there and [ __ ]
that's why so many of those [ __ ]
fixed-wing guys they get it on the
[ __ ] ground and they still die
when they hit a [ __ ] tree because
that thing is not designed to hit
anything it's designed to fly it's all
Weight and Balance so you're basically
you're in a [ __ ] golf cart and you
[ __ ] hit a tree
it's 60 knots or whatever the [ __ ] you
got to be flying it I don't know I don't
know I don't know anything about fixing
how fast you have to be going to still
you know maintain lift or whatever but
it's terrifying where is a helicopter
um all right really quickly and I'm
gonna sound like a [ __ ] I know so
basically you know when you watch like a
Rambo movie and they shoot out the the
tail rotor and then the [ __ ]
helicopter starts spinning around
okay and then they [ __ ] basically
if you roll off the throttle
okay
the engine is no longer turning the main
rotor what's turning the main rotor is
your your descent back down to the Earth
in the [ __ ] air rushing up through
the rotor the main rotor
okay you no longer need the tail rotor
the tail rotor basically compensates for
the [ __ ] uh like if if your main
rotor turns counterclockwise
counterclockwise it wants to turn the
ship clockwise
so that's why you have the tail rotor on
the back on site it's it's compensating
for that torque so you can keep the
[ __ ] thing straight so you don't just
spin around like a [ __ ] top basically
and if you see a helicopter that has two
main rotors
basically I guess it would be both like
both giant rotors the reason why they
don't need a tail road is because one
turns clockwise the other one turns
counterclockwise both offsetting the
torque and it keeps it [ __ ] straight
so basically
if God forbid
you had an engine failure all you do is
you roll off the throttle
and the thing that I fly is you want to
be going about 65 knots and that's the
speed you want to keep it at and as your
RPMs come up you catch them you pull up
power which is the weirdest [ __ ]
thing because you think if you didn't
want it to go up you push it down but
you actually pull it up
and you just [ __ ]
just like that you [ __ ] Glide all the
way down you pick and you're doing trim
air speed RPM trim air speed RPM trim
air is doing that and then as the
ground's coming up you know you're
picking your spot as the ground comes up
gentle off cyclic you go into a flare
you basically
stop in the air
push the cyclic forward and then you
level
okay and at that point and then you just
drop 40 feet you just drop to the ground
and at right about 10 feet off the deck
you pull the power which is like pulling
up the emergency brake and that last
little bit of power slows you down you
drop like a [ __ ] Daisy
now
I don't know how to do that yet I can do
it all the way down to the flare and
that's my favorite [ __ ] thing to do
and I've thought about that a zillion
times on my couch
literally reenacting it and thinking it
and believe it or not it actually helps
you because I hadn't flown since
November 5th and I went out and we did
some autos and I had two of the best
ones I ever did
I forgot to look at the RPMs because I
was so psyched that I was in trim and
that I was at 65 knots and I was falling
you know at the uh descending I should
say at the right rate of speed and uh
that's my favorite thing because it's
all about what the [ __ ] am I I just want
to have those things so down that I can
actually enjoy
flying around so
I would say that that was the most the
most fun and another time I took out an
r44
which is the four passenger and I flew
up
uh
up the coast
um right by LAX out by the water and you
got to be 150 feet off the ocean as you
go through Bravo airspace and you're
looking at LAX where you took off from a
zillion [ __ ] times it's just a
different View
and then you come back up on the other
side and I made a right at the [ __ ]
what the hell was it the uh
the ferris wheel there it's Santa Monica
then I flew right up I just followed
Santa Monica like you're driving down
the road except you're in the air
went over all the houses in Beverly
Hills
just kept going and going and going
until I got out to [ __ ] you know over
where I live flew over my [ __ ] house
flew around some more out to the valley
then I flew over [ __ ] Dodger Stadium
so the next time I do that flight I'm
gonna fly over [ __ ] Dodger Stadium
and then over the Rose Bowl that's what
I want to do and um
I don't know I don't know about fixed
Wing I like fixed Wing is fixed Wing
seems like if you want to go if I wanted
to start flying myself to my gigs which
I don't because I'm not going to make
any money the amount of money I have to
spend to [ __ ] rent the plane and the
Jet Fuel and all of that [ __ ] [ __ ] I
don't want to do that but um
what I like most about flying a
helicopter is it's uh it's truly like
flying where you can just you can stop
in the middle of the air like a [ __ ]
hummingbird
and you go out over the ocean you see
porpoises and [ __ ] that looks like a
[ __ ] giant shark and they need to see
a goddamn bunch of people surfing and
you sit there from that bird's eye view
going yeah that right there is why I
don't go in the [ __ ] ocean look at
that thing what the [ __ ] is that thing
Swimming by itself
sharks and loners
so anyways
um
yeah I would say I could go on and on a
forever I would like eventually to uh
who's getting who I'd like to have that
[ __ ] helicopter that the guy had in
uh Magnum P.I I would eventually love to
have that in fact the next time I go to
Hawaii there's a helicopter tour that
they take you up in uh one of those what
he we 500 whatever the [ __ ] thing is
they got it paint it just like that and
they'll take you over the [ __ ]
volcanoes and the waterfalls and all
that and I'm dying to do that [ __ ]
um
but uh yeah I don't know I thought I was
too dumb to get through [ __ ] Ground
School I still have to take the test and
all that [ __ ] that's what I'm gonna be
knocking out here before I go to
Australia
and um and then the second I get license
I'm immediately gonna take the advanced
auto rotation class where I have to
take it all the way to the flare and
take it all the way down to the [ __ ]
ground which they basically don't let
you do because they don't want you
beating the [ __ ] out of the helicopters
um you'd be surprised what those kids
can take
especially with some of the [ __ ]
Landings I've had I might as well talk
about this [ __ ] one of the most [ __ ]
up things ever is the first time
when they let you you solo just
basically fly the traffic pattern around
the airport
you know
I think if you're a sane person you
never think you're ready to do that but
they kind of know when you're ready
and then they just have you set the
thing down they go all right I'm
stepping out fly the [ __ ] pattern
and you sit there and act like yeah I
got this [ __ ] and then you fly it and
you can't believe what you know
like the second time I did it
a [ __ ] jet blue plane was landing and
I had to hold over this building
this hanger
they called me out my [ __ ] tail
number and
told me to hold and I did it
I was like uh
it was weird it was really weird like oh
I actually know how to do that I mean I
knew I knew how to do that but I didn't
know how I knew I didn't know that I
knew how to do that by myself and that's
by the way what I call soloing flying by
myself
so anyways
um what do I enjoy about it all of it I
love that as much it's as much fun as
playing drums and doing stand-up it's
just another fun thing to do and
if you got the [ __ ] time to do it why
wouldn't you go do it so
I did it was uh something um that kind
of came about
through freaking out about living in LA
and being in conspiracy theory and then
I did that
bit about the um
you know that guy committing suicide and
jumping out of the helicopter
and uh I was already into helicopters
but I I really it was one of those
things in my head I just said that I I
couldn't do it like I I couldn't ever
get to ground school I couldn't I
actually really enjoyed it
um some of it some of the [ __ ] you know
what the [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate I hate all
that [ __ ]
you know all that [ __ ] radio stuff
and the [ __ ] you know who do you
contact if this happens and all that
[ __ ] you basically need to know I find
that stuff really tedious but learning
about weather
and uh learning the markings all that
[ __ ] around the airport was [ __ ]
interesting how the [ __ ] thing flies
to actually understand that now
um
it's pretty uh it's pretty amazing and
you guys remember me and me a [ __ ]
year ago I didn't understand how a plane
flew so uh
yeah
if you think you can't do something
you'd be [ __ ] surprised so there you
go that's kind of uplifting isn't it I
hope it is um anyways another Year's
gone by everybody thank you for everyone
who's come up to my shows anybody who's
hyped anything that I'm doing uh I got
some [ __ ] for your [ __ ] asses next
year I'm telling you
I'm telling you I just made a pilot that
I think of might go could be a funny
[ __ ] show I'm working on my new hour
I got a sick ass [ __ ] tour coming up
of the South
and I'm thinking of maybe doing another
red state tour and then hitting all the
other ones I got a [ __ ]
I'm gonna do some dates in Boston my
hometown I haven't been there in a
minute
a good couple of years actually come in
February I haven't been there in a
couple years so it's going to be a big
year for me next year and then of course
I got F is for family coming out at the
end of the goddamn year and it kills me
every week that I can't tell you
anything more about it but I don't want
to ruin it for you it's going to be a
[ __ ] monster I feel who knows
who knows uh that's it everybody have a
merry Christmas happy Hanukkah
Kwanzaa whatever the [ __ ] it is you do
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast NFL Edition
sponsored by bet MGM and this week holy
[ __ ] we are previewing week number 16
man can't believe there's only a couple
more of these left uh what a weird weird
[ __ ] season uh it has been and uh
unfortunately our comrade our partner
uh the uh the other the other half of
this show is um is is down and out man
not feeling well right Andrew we can't
speak
yeah bill is uh bill is incapacitated
he's uh he's you know he's he's he had
I'm not gonna diagnose him but he has he
doesn't have code but he has something
that's been going around he's been cough
having coughing fits and uh dude
everybody I know is sick like when I
tell you like people are missing events
um my sister and brother-in-law actually
now do have covet
um but then my kids had the RSV the
other thing
um bill has been sick and then you know
as we as we speak bill is at a doctor's
uh So for anybody out there bitching
about why bill doesn't have time to be
on this uh he he would much rather be uh
on this uh yeah than uh you know letting
me step in for him so yeah guys bill
would much rather be you know telling uh
his picks to us and giving his reasoning
for NFL picks then having somebody
asking where he was last week same thing
he was feeling okay
so just that's what it is so we'll uh we
got his picks everybody guys enough with
the [ __ ] enough with the comments of
like hey what the [ __ ] you want to know
what the [ __ ] people get sick and they
travel sorry we're not all [ __ ] home
sitting around you people get sick sorry
so you know hey I don't know why I'm
defensive but you know hey [ __ ] calm
down all it takes is one comment you
know sets you up Paul that's what I mean
no no one comment hey what the [ __ ] is
going I don't know somebody's [ __ ]
sick and and has a coughing fits and
can't speak all right but anyway we are
here don't worry Bill submitted his
picks hey he wasn't that sick okay
uh uh he he was able to submit his picks
Andrew has Bill's picks bill will go
first this week then I will go first um
what did Bill go last week because I
went one and three he went one and three
as well so me and Bill uh not the best
time to to start to flail but look we
got three weeks left we have 16 17 and
18 left I went one and three bringing me
to 28 31 and 1 which is two and a half
games back with three weeks to go now I
can go back and get to like eight on
Eight Below like I was or I surge back
in the last week to have a triumphant
type of above 500 we shall see but first
but first
we got a shout out to sponsor it's
betmgm everybody you guys know Ben and
Jim the best live lines out there in the
game okay uh as you guys know if you
team up with Ben and GM through anything
better all you have to do is download
the betmgm app and use bonus code Burr
that's b-u-r-r it could not be more easy
and once you put in uh Burr b-u-r-r with
the code you will get access to amazing
cool stuff deals uh our parlay on Monday
night which hey you know what we're
trying to figure it out but
um all you have to do with that is you
put as little as ten dollars in the
account and they will match up to a
thousand dollars guys even if you lose
okay they will match up to a thousand
dollars in free bets uh even if you lose
so just go to the betmgm store uh I'm
sorry the App Store download the betmgm
app use bonus code burr Put as little as
10 bucks in and they will match up to
one thousand dollars
in a free bet so there you go uh nothing
to lose gamble responsibly uh bet MGM is
the best and uh here we go we are going
into week number 16 here okay which
means wow we have 12 more picks each for
the year
okay we are in Striking Distance
uh we are in Striking Distance I don't
know Andrew I don't know who anybody is
at the end of it I mean the Carolina
Panthers they start to seem like they
turn a corner okay the Jets their
quarterback situation nobody knows Tom
Brady can't win a game all of a sudden
or did he win that game no he lost
didn't he I had them they well they
didn't cover I know that yeah no
yeah Tampa I I don't know who Tampa is
uh I don't know who any of these teams
are the only constant in the League this
year has been Philadelphia Eagles it
pains me to say but I got to tell you
something I gotta tell you something
everybody
that said my New York football Giants
were out
they went into a red hot Commander's
building and when I say red hot the
commanders have been red hot fighting
back the commanders on their run beat
the Eagles let's not forget that the
commanders gave the Eagles a loss and
then just kept kind of winning we tied
them in New York we had to beat them in
Washington and we did
um we are knocking on the door of the
playoffs we will see what happened but
let's get into our picks and uh books
what if the books lost last week to the
Bengals that was the loss the Bucks lost
the Bengals I mean the New England
Patriots instead of going to overtime
they decide to turn it into a circus
throw the ball backwards I mean that's
something Lord knows what Belichick did
in practice this week I don't know man
that is like put it this way when the
New England Patriots I'm gonna I'm gonna
go back a second when the Bill Belichick
coached New England Patriots start
throwing the ball backwards when it's a
AI at the end of the game this is the
weirdest NFL season that I have seen I
don't know it's a wrap on the Patriots
when you're I'll be honest man and I'm
not just saying this I'm kind of happy
I'm only two and a half games back with
everything that's gone on the Packers
now can run the table are they gonna
suck me back in I don't know I don't
know but Andrew I know that uh
bill has the first pick so you have his
first pick so let's get into it uh for
Bill's first pick he is going with the
Bears
eight and a half
uh in Chicago against the eleven and
three Buffalo Bills
[Music]
I don't know what Buffalo's playing for
see these are those weird times now I
think Buffalo still has some stuff to do
but like these are the weird weeks now
where like is somebody gonna rest
there's a star gonna play a little bit
and if there's any kind of pain or
tweaking I'm gonna sit down
I like his pick though because he's
getting eight and a half points so he's
starting the game up and he's in Chicago
that could go either way like that could
be like Chicago gets a garbage touchdown
to cover at the end
um
all right well
here's
here's what I'm gonna do
I'm either gonna go down or I'm going to
go I mean listen here's the thing I'm
either gonna crash and burn or I'm going
to go down swinging but I'm gonna set it
off with tonight and I hate losing
the the Thursday night game because then
you're like oh dude I don't know what's
gonna happen this week but I'm gonna
tell you something
Trevor Lawrence in the Jacksonville
Jaguars are on a streak right now seems
like Trevor Lawrence has kind of turned
some [ __ ] around
I'm gonna take them tonight in New York
against the Jets they are two and a half
Point dogs okay the Jaguars are two and
a half Point dogs but they're just
winning Andrew what was the score of the
Jacksonville game last week because I
know that they had to come back but
I believe the Jags came back and won
yeah it was 40 to 34. uh the Jets the
Jags won uh over over maybe Dallas right
now and I believe that was in Dallas
right no in Jacksonville oh it was
interesting they were in Dallas the week
before for the uh Texans game oh that's
right that's right okay so yeah I like
I like the Jags tonight to come into New
York they're two and a half Point dogs
which to me is kind of like almost like
a Pick Em I'm gonna take the Jags
getting two and a half tonight I think
that the jets are in disarray a
quarterback they have a good defense but
I think Trevor Lawrence might have
turned the corner we'll see what happens
I like it
for Bill's second pick he is going with
the Tennessee Titans I mean he's three
and a half I mean he's been on the
Tennessee Titans the way I was on the
pack he can't let go of the Tennessee
Titans who are they playing the Packers
the Titans are going up against all
right the wrong week there uh they're
going up against the Texans
Texans
and there it's in Tennessee three and a
half points
um oh man I mean look they should win
that game by that gun to your head you
gotta like that pick you gotta you gotta
you gotta you gotta think that the type
is I don't think that the Texans are
gonna show up with anything uh we
haven't seen well at this point the
Texans need to get their first round
pick right that first pick yeah
um which they'll get even if they win
all right dude this is a tough tough
game man
this is a really really tough game
do I pick it's the Cincinnati Bengals
versus the Patriots after the Patriots
and Cincinnati won last week right
did Cincinnati win last week
yeah yeah the Bengals they beat they
beat the Bucks
they beat the bucks on the road they
looked good
um oh my God minus three the Patriots or
the Patriots done can you just I'm sorry
can you just give me the Patriots record
uh
uh yeah they are seven and seven
oh my God this is because what did
Belichick say in that in that meeting
I mean belichaw you guys out of your
[ __ ] you're playing [ __ ] you guys are
playing hot potato with a football first
time first time there's only two times
I've ever really had a problem with
Belichick one one was the packages that
he ran uh in the uh in the Super Bowl uh
where he didn't play his top cornerbacks
I don't want to get into that but
anyways he did say this week when they
asked him why they didn't throw a Hail
Mary did you hear what he said
yeah
it was too far
it was too far
all right Isaac you know Bill you're
losing me oh my God not not in general
but that's a tough that's a tough thing
that's a tough thing it's just like yeah
I'll make a [ __ ] out of us you know let
me go [ __ ] out of me bill come on uh
dude this is tough man this is actually
this is the week I'm gonna say this this
is the toughest week that I've seen on
paper only because of where teams are
record wise and some of these games are
just you know uh are really really tough
um
I'm gonna take this is crazy dude
this is crazy forget the Cincinnati
thing okay
forget the Cincinnati thing
I'm gonna take the Green Bay Packers for
the first time since I jumped off that
train
okay I know people are slapping their
heads right now
I'm just gonna say this I think
I think I like the reason I'm doing is
because it's over three points that's it
okay I'm not saying the Packers are
going to win the game I like the four
points and I'm also also my thought
processes you see I have to explain
myself to the fans listening because
they're like no versie was he had
therapy and he got better he got better
he went from all those games and he got
better he he was listening to reason
here's my thing
I'm not back on the Patriot I mean on
the Packers I don't think they're gonna
Roar through and make some crazy
historic run I mean if they do God bless
her I'm not saying that I'm saying the
four points they could be down like 11
or 10 and then a garbage touchdown at
the end to cover with the four so that's
my that's my rationale here
okay does that make sense Andrew can
like yeah I I mean it's it's not the
craziest Packers pick event right it's
not the craziest craziest one uh last
week I mean they beat the Rams which I
guess is not you know much to talk about
but they
I don't even want to say it but like the
Run game looked pretty good you know
right that's what I mean like Dylan Like
The Run game look good and and and and
Miami been okay against the run you know
past weeks I I don't know I don't know
I'm not even gonna no that's that's a
thing I think I think that
the slight hope that that organization
has to still not be eliminated will make
them run the ball play smarter but I'm
taking the Four Points uh I'm gonna take
the four points and see like I said I
see them losing by like 10 late and then
Roger's throwing some touchdown that
might not matter to fight back and show
a little fight so there you go I got
Packers plus four I have to take a dog
because I think I'm taking the rest
favorites
all right for Bill's third pick he's
going with the Detroit Lions minus two
and a half in Carolina
I mean it's one of those things where I
think gun to your head that's an easy
pick but the way things are who knows
but I I like it I guess I mean the Lions
seem to be roaring back no pun intended
they seem to be kind of
you know
my son would go dead that was so
cringe-worthy did you just say roaring
ahead and be like hey you know what son
I'm the one making money doing jokes
why why are the Eagles dogs that means
people are resting because Jalen hurts
that means because Jalen hurts is not
playing and Dallas needs to win that
game that's minus I mean but Dallas is
already in the playoffs so guess what
everybody Paulie's not touching that one
I'm not touching that one
five and a half over Eagles five and a
half over the uh the Cowboys you know
like that
Eagles five and a half now you know what
let's do it let's do it I'm gonna do the
Cincinnati Bengals beating the Patriots
dude
you know something the Patriots
shouldn't be seven and seven I know they
probably gotta ask Raymond this week I
think everybody thinks they're gonna
bounce back but you know something the
Cincinnati Bengals are better they're
favored by three for a reason they
should win that game
um I'm gonna take Cincinnati minus three
over the Patriots to put the Patriots
out of their misery I think that that
freaking circus play was kind of a Kill
Shot maybe for him
yep yep I get uh I mean
I think so yeah I mean Patriots like
like we said about Panthers like they're
not gonna come out and do something you
haven't you don't think you've seen you
know
um for Bill's fourth pick
the San Francisco 49ers minus seven
in San Francisco against
the Washington Commanders
okay San Francisco 49ers over the
commanders commanders got to bounce back
after the Giants to have any shot I
don't know that's
you know what I was thinking about
something before
I was thinking about going head-to-head
with Bill on one of those but
um
the Kansas City is clinched see this is
what sucks dude this is what sucks
because these guys clenched
um they almost got embarrassed though by
the oh by the way all you people talking
[ __ ] about
um how's the pick look now with the you
know you picked this you know what
Kansas City shouldn't have went to
overtime but they did win by six they
did win by six
um
I'm gonna take the Kansas City Chiefs
Chiefs by by 10 at home against the
Seattle Seahawks
they almost lost they almost lost to the
Texans they went to overtime with the
Texans they got to be pissed I think
Seattle's finito I think the Chiefs just
wiped it just [ __ ] blow them out
because I think they're still playing
for what the buy and home and home is
that is that what it is I don't know man
I don't want to touch the Giants and
Vikings so was that my fourth pick or
third uh that was your fourth uh you've
got the Jags the Packers the Bengals and
the Chiefs
and to review bills he's got the Bears
the Titans the Lions and the Niners
um guys I'm to be honest with you I'll
be honest with all you guys this is I
can honestly say week 16 is probably the
one week that I'm going like
I could go 4-0 I could go oh and four I
could go two and two I'll go one and
three three I don't I literally don't
know I don't know but I would like to
start with a W I'd like to start with a
W with the Jags tonight
uh probably one of the the the the
biggest games that I think of the week
which happens to be Segway the Monday
night special yeah that would say the
biggest games to not touch
is the Colts and the Chargers
yeah we're going to get into that in a
minute but that's the Monday night
special the Colts and the Chargers on
Monday night and and for the listeners
uh do you had mentioned this last week a
lot of Saturday games so everybody
should be uh have a have a happy uh
happy Saturday Sunday listen Santa Claus
is coming early for real this year okay
because Santa Claus he may show up
Sunday morning but Saturday night you
got a lot of football to watch and guys
look I'm not trying to I'm not trying to
Pat myself on the back here because they
might not even get in the playoffs
but the Chargers my pick for the Super
Bowl for the AFC
Justin Herbert that throw down the
sideline that he had the throw he had
down the sideline that I was just like
dude that kid could make any throw and
that team should scare anybody with
Keenan Allen Mike Williams they have
Eckler they have a good tight end they
have a good defense and Justin Herbert
is healthy like I said the ribs are
healed I like them for the Monday night
special I like them to win by five and
beat the Colts the Colts I mean look
guys you can't be down let's just talk
about this for a second Andrew I know
this is just a pick thing but
you can't be down 33 to nothing
or or or I should say you can't be
winning 33 to nothing in Minnesota and
lose that game like that you can't be in
the third quarter halfway through the
third quarter up 30 and [ __ ] that up
okay I think it goes to show a new coach
like Jeff Saturday I think Matt Ryan
should have never been passing I would
have run run milk clock then try to dunk
and try to get first downs and really
try to but like the fact that he's
lining up he's getting passes that could
be picked off I think it was uh it was
tough man like I I didn't feel bad for
the Cults but dude and I'll tell you
something when uh did you watch the game
Andrew I didn't know I just watched
highlights I didn't say oh dude when the
Vikings went from like 36 to 7 to then
36 to 14. once they got to 21 I'm going
dude this is we're about to see some
[ __ ] here and um you can't let that
happen I think it's a combination of not
being co coached properly and you know
just everything that's happened with the
with them I think for the Monday night
special for me and you could talk me out
of it I don't know but I know I I think
we have to go I think we have to go
charges to cover I mean to to to to beat
him right here and I'm gonna I I agree
we could do moneyline if you don't wanna
uh if you don't wanna chance uh going
against the spread but I I think the
biggest thing just with the Chargers
the reason I think the Chargers have
struggled obviously their defense even
in the games they've won they've let up
like 24 points the charges haven't
really been blowing anybody out there
they haven't had any like 14 point you
know def the 14 point difference wins
since like you know the beginning of the
Season middle of the season I I could be
off by a game or two but but
um the Chargers are giving up a lot of
points
and in this case I just but I just don't
think that the cult I don't think the
Colts are going to put up 24 against the
Chargers I just don't see it no they're
having defensive problems but not not
that many I think like you said that the
coaching you know what I'm gonna do
something right now do it I'm calling an
audible right now as I'm thinking about
this and I'm looking at this I'm gonna
call an audible I like it do it I'm
taking away my Chief's bet
okay I'm taking away my Chiefs minus 10
to the Seahawks I'm going to take that
away and I'm going to take
and here's why it just hit me Herbert is
healthy Herbert's guys around him are
healthy every reason I said they would
win last week okay I think they're
finally have their core at a great time
of the season and should they beat the
Colts by five or more yes they should so
I'll take that logic so guys I'm
switching my picks I hope you didn't
turn it off and write down versy's picks
I'm taking the Los Angeles
Chargers minus four and a half watch the
Chiefs blow out the Seahawks I feel like
such a dick you know but you know what
as we're talking about it and we're
taking them for the Monday night special
and I'm listening to myself going like
my mind going yeah Herbert's ribs are
healed just like I said last week and
they won so I'm gonna take that and um
and we'll take them with the Monday
night special you want to take the money
line I would say just do moneyline all
right so for the Monday night special
this is what I like you tell me
for the Monday night special here's two
and then we'll do a fun one okay
so for the two I think the Chargers
money line
and Justin Herbert to throw one
okay I think again he's a Slinger and I
like that we're not gonna do what we do
at Rogers the two by the way Baker
Mayfield not running for [ __ ] eight
yards I mean what is Go I mean not once
I mean this is the craziest Year guys
you didn't even lose five yards I don't
even think I don't even think you got
sacked yeah I think he got yeah dude we
could have taken it the other way I mean
yeah no we actually went backwards
though more than he went far I mean it
was brutal
all right but I like this I like this
we're going to keep it simple because we
got to get a Monday night we got four or
five of them last year we have zero this
year and we're at week 16. okay but I
will say this we did warn you guys if
you want to go with our money line picks
or certain things and we have hit some
of those we just haven't got the
combination the parlay but this week
this week will be different because the
charges with the money line Justin
Herbert to throw one now Andrew let's
give them some fun ones what what do we
got well I mean you know you want to
play it safe across all three bets or
you want to get because I mean the the
Keenan Allen I mean Keenan Allen over 70
yards and so over 70 receiving yards I
mean I think that's a good one I think
he's I certainly he's going to score a
touchdown what do we got for Eckler what
do we got for Eckler yeah Eckler is uh
uh over under for 50 50 rushing uh 45
receiving anytime touchdown so I mean
Eckler's not a bad one
Keenan Allen though man I just that
feels safe feels like if uh you know
Keelan Keelan Allen Keenan out for 70.
or even just an even just a touchdown
even just a receiving touchdown
uh what are other ones let me see I mean
if if if uh if Herbert is likely to
throw one Keenan Allen's probably likely
to be on the receiving end of that um
all right let's do it let's do it but
but I'll read them out just to people uh
let's see uh Mike Williams over under 60
yards receiving uh over under five over
under five receptions I'm sorry Keenan
Allen over under five receptions uh not
rushing so if you think he's gonna get
more
uh more than five receptions that's not
a bad one
um
Zach Moss rushing over under
you want to do Keenan Allen anytime
touchdown
yeah it feels safe it's either that or
five receptions because I mean
yeah whatever you think Paul
whatever you think well all right so
hold on a second five receptions is
safer than a touchdown
right but I mean what is his average you
know five receptions is still D because
he could get two you know yeah I think
let me check uh
uh yeah
[Music]
um
see if I can get that on Keenan
I don't want to bore anybody kill any
time here looking upstairs but let's see
um
yeah I don't know man I don't know it's
a tough one dude like I love I love the
Chargers to win and I love Herbert to
throw one the question is
and their every down back is Eckler we
could do an echler anytime touchdown
uh yeah
I mean he's a running back right
uh
or one of them like well he does both
but no I I clearly yeah uh
I mean dude if we lose this one
if we lose this one obviously he's got
165. he's he's gotten the ball 165 times
this year
divided by 15 I mean yeah it's you're
right in that average
um yeah
um Eckler Eckler is their all-purpose
guy he's Eckler is a runner he gets the
he you know they're gonna always run or
try something with him first I think
that's actually a really good idea all
right Eckler anytime is probably better
than Keenan Allen because yeah because
if if they're within like five yards
like they might throw them one yeah I
don't know okay we're taking a lot of
time with this for you just so you know
we're taking a lot of time with this for
you but let's go Chargers money line
Herbert to throw one and Eckler to score
on any any time touchdown doesn't have
to be rushing doesn't have to be
receiving just Eckler to score a
touchdown there you go that's the Monday
night special it's Chargers across the
board they're healthy they're rolling I
think the Colts are reeling and
um I think that lost the Colts comeback
man to Minnesota I think that that's
just that's a that's a tough one to
swallow uh going into week 16 especially
when you're not in the mix of the
playoffs so there you have it you have
our picks I also changed the pick you
have the change of the pick correct so
we don't have okay
um there you go guys I can't believe
Bill laid off Denver I figured he was
gonna he was gonna pick Russell well you
know I figured he was gonna pick Russell
Stover to throw one you know
[Laughter]
the thing with Bill is if it's not if
it's not you know Denver messing up
Russell's name it's the Titans and he he
stayed true to that did true to one one
out of one um by the way guys
um we want to thank you guys so much for
listening to the anything better podcast
and we want to let you guys know that um
we appreciate you guys rate and
reviewing it
um you know and I know the last couple
with uh bet MGM we're dealing with
traveling and sickness and stuff like
that but we're gonna get back on the
last couple of weeks
um also want to thank everybody who's
jumped on the verzie effect which is
doing fantastic please check that out
and I had a big episode this week with
Mark Norman it's doing fantastic uh Bill
had um a big guest on his podcast to uh
talk about a movie coming out so you
could check out the Monday Morning
podcast so thank you guys for listening
to all of our podcasts subscribe go to
the YouTube channels
um we really really uh appreciate that
and guys thank you so much for buying
tickets to my show Andrew the kid is
going to be doing uh almost a a 400 seat
theater at the Royal Theater in Toronto
tickets are going that's January 28th
it's going to be my first real tour date
of 2023. hit that up and then right
after that the next week February 2nd
and 3rd I'm a Gotham at home New York
City that's a Thursday and Friday
tickets are already going for that I
want to sell those out and add shows and
then fourth 14th of um 14th of February
which is Valentine's Day bring your date
and see me headline Pittsburgh improv
with my boy Joe bartnick on the show
Pittsburgh Zone uh rest in peace to
Franco Harris Franco Harris by the way
um terrible heard the guy was great so
rest in peace
um and uh thoughts and prayers with his
family and uh there you go all my other
dates Tampa coming up where else we
going we're going to Providence Rhode
Island we're going to Utah we're going
to Denver we're going to Austin Texas
we're going to all these cool places
Chicago Zanies all up all verses com
um and those are our picks guys uh again
go to bedmgm the best lines out there
download the app use bonus code Burr
b-u-r-r you'll get the best live uh
lines as they happen and uh we love
working with them you put in as little
as ten dollars up to a thousand they
will match your bet even if you lose how
does it work you download the app betmgm
you put in bonus code b u r r Burr and
that's it and you click on the Monday
night special to get the parlay this
week Chargers to win the game Herbert to
throw a touchdown and Eckler anytime
touchdown in the game and you will be in
the money we'll be back on track
hopefully me and Bill are both back on
track this week 500 or better uh enjoy
your holiday everybody happy safe one
enjoy Christmas enjoy the holidays uh
New Year's we should we'll be back
before New Year's though right we'll be
back before New Year's we'll be back
before the new year so we'll do one more
but before 2023
for myself Bill Burr Andrew demless
we're out of here enjoy